My name is Camo.
我的名字是卡莫。
I'm from Istero, Florida.
我来自佛罗里达州伊斯特罗。
What does how I make your mother mean to me?
我如何让你妈妈对我来说意味着什么？
It means a lot actually.
实际上这意味着很多。
I started watching it early high school.
我从高中就开始看。
I fell in love with it man.
我爱上了这个人。
Like I've watched it ever since.
就像我从那时起就看过它一样。
I'm in college now.
我现在上大学了。
I really resonated with a lot of the characters in the show, but mostly Ted and his music choices.
我确实与剧中的很多角色产生了共鸣，但主要是泰德和他的音乐选择。
I noticed you know like a lot of the times when Ted falls in love it's George Harrison will play and you know he loves Otis Redding so sometimes like cigarettes and coffee will play.
我注意到，很多时候，当泰德坠入爱河时，乔治·哈里森会扮演，你知道他爱奥蒂斯·雷丁，所以有时会扮演香烟和咖啡。
It's like he had this soundtrack to his life.
就好像他的生活里有这样的配乐一样。
And I remember I showed up to my entrepreneurship class.
我记得我参加了我的创业课程。
They asked us, you know, what do you want to do with your life?
他们问我们，你知道，你想做什么？
I knew in that moment that it was music.
那一刻我知道那是音乐。
You know, I wanted to give people a soundtrack to their lives.
你知道，我想给人们的生活配乐。
I wanted to help people.
我想帮助别人。
You know, it's the reason I started a record label this year, you know, from the ground up.
你知道，这就是我今年从头开始创办唱片公司的原因。
Me and a bunch of people, a bunch of nerds about music.
我和一群人，一群音乐迷。
So I guess I love how I met your mother for a lot of reasons, but it definitely taught me how to care about what you love and not be ashamed to nerd out about it.
所以我想我喜欢我遇见你母亲的方式有很多原因，但它确实教会了我如何关心你所爱的东西，而不是羞于对它痴迷。
And if you surround yourself with the right people, they'll support it.
如果你身边都是合适的人，他们就会支持你。
So hope this reaches you guys.
所以希望这能传达给你们。
Big fan of the show.
该剧的忠实粉丝。
Have a great day.
祝你有美好的一天。
Hello and welcome to another episode of how we made your mother, where I, Joshua Adner, sit with my very good friend, Craig Thomas.
大家好，欢迎收看我们如何造就你母亲的另一集，我，约书亚·阿德纳，和我的好朋友克雷格·托马斯坐在一起。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey, they're Josh.
嘿，他们是乔什。
And we talk about a TV show that we made now many years ago.
我们谈论了我们多年前制作的一部电视节目。
Together, it was called How I Met Your Mother.
合起来，它就被称为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
It ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014.
该剧于 2005 年至 2014 年在哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 播出。
I played Ted Mosby on that show, The Eye and How I Met Your Mother.
我在《眼睛》和《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中扮演泰德·莫斯比。
And Craig co-created the show with his college bud, Carter Bayes.
克雷格与他的大学好友卡特·贝叶斯共同创作了该节目。
And yeah, we just heard an awesome voice note from.
是的，我们刚刚听到了一段很棒的语音留言。
I loved that.
我喜欢那个。
That was so great.
那真是太棒了。
I feel, the music part is such a big part of the show and such a big part of our bond and Carter's bond with you.
我觉得，音乐部分是节目的重要组成部分，也是我们以及卡特与你之间的纽带的重要组成部分。
Like music really was, we all liked the same stuff, right?
就像音乐一样，我们都喜欢同样的东西，对吧？
It really put us on the same page right away in music.
它确实让我们在音乐上立刻达成了共识。
So the fact that he, music speaks to this, to that guy is like the best.
所以事实上，音乐对这个人来说，对那个人来说是最好的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
You know, we could, we really need to have Andy Gowen on the show, our music supervisor who also incidentally was the music supervisor on both of my movies on Happy, Thank You, More, Please and Liberal Arts, just because we had had this great music vibe going already.
你知道，我们可以，我们真的需要安迪·高文（Andy Gowen）参加演出，他是我们的音乐总监，顺便说一句，他也是我的两部电影《快乐》、《谢谢你》、《更多》、《请》和《人文艺术》的音乐总监，只是因为我们已经有了这种很棒的音乐氛围。
Yeah.
是的。
But speaking of music, I mean, you could really, if you are a music fan, I think how I met your mother has a lot of delights, you know, a lot of like classic old songs that you would definitely know and a lot of new kind of ear worms that we broke, you know, some bands on the show.
但说到音乐，我的意思是，你真的可以，如果你是一个音乐迷，我想我遇见你母亲的方式有很多乐趣，你知道，很多像你肯定知道的经典老歌，还有很多我们打破的新型耳虫，你知道，节目中的一些乐队。
You guys were always so great about, I would play you some stuff and some of it really caught you and you put it on the show and and I got to become friends with the bands and the artists and I was also when I joined Twitter, I started doing a song of the day.
你们总是很棒，我会给你们演奏一些东西，其中一些真的吸引了你们，你们把它放在节目中，我和乐队和艺术家成为了朋友，当我加入 Twitter 时，我开始做一首当天的歌曲。
Remember I used to do that for years?
还记得我多年来一直这样做吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You should bring that back.
你应该把它带回来。
I'm not on Twitter though.
不过我不在推特上。
I'm not on Twitter, RIP Twitter.
我不在推特上，安息吧推特。
But in this episode, it ends with just jumping to the end.
但在这一集中，它只是跳到了最后。
We're doing Ted Mosby Architect today, episode four, season two.
今天我们正在制作《泰德·莫斯比建筑师》第二季第四集。
Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
亚历克，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出。
This episode was written by Kristin Newman and it aired on October 9th, 2006.
本集由克里斯汀·纽曼编剧，于 2006 年 10 月 9 日播出。
Well, almost exactly 19, it's October 19 years ago.
嗯，几乎正好19，那是19年前的10月。
And we're basically sitting here on that day.
那天我们基本上就坐在这里。
We're recording right around then.
那时我们正在录音。
So symmetry.
所以对称。
Well, and this episode just just jumping to the end ends with a song by the Decemberists called Here I Dremped I Was an Architect.
好吧，这一集刚刚跳到最后，以十二月主义者的一首歌曲《Here I Dremped I Was an Architect》结束。
Is that what it was called?
是这么叫的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, people loved that song on the show.
是的，人们喜欢节目中的那首歌。
It's it's just it's written for the show.
这只是为了节目而写的。
It's the perfect placement.
这是完美的位置。
I got to give credit where it's due.
我必须给予应得的信任。
Gloria Calderon-Kellett pitched that song.
格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆-凯利特 (Gloria Calderon-Kellett) 演唱了这首歌。
That was her.
那是她。
She had a very cool mix of like, she knew we loved music.
她有一种非常酷的组合，她知道我们喜欢音乐。
She was like, here's a bunch of songs that say hymnium to me.
她说，这是一堆对我来说赞美诗的歌曲。
And one of them was that song.
其中之一就是那首歌。
And I think that's how we got it to put it on there.
我想这就是我们把它放在那里的方式。
So it really could come from anywhere.
所以它确实可以来自任何地方。
Everyone knew we loved music.
每个人都知道我们热爱音乐。
And I again, almost like the balance of Ashton song in season one, when I would watch the show or know that it was ending with a song like by the decemberous who at that point I think they were having they were kind of breaking right around them like they had this really big album I think that song is from that record right and you know we got to be at the forefront of that and I and it would it would lead me to go oh my god I can't believe I'm on a sitcom on CBS that has the coolest music it always delighted me.
我再次，几乎就像第一季中阿什顿歌曲的平衡一样，当我观看节目或知道它以十二月的一首歌结束时，我认为他们在他们周围打破了，就像他们有一张非常大的专辑一样，我认为这首歌来自那张唱片，你知道我们必须站在最前沿，我，它会引导我去哦天哪，我不敢相信我在哥伦比亚广播公司的情景喜剧中，有最酷的音乐总是让我高兴。
Cam I love that you singled out Otis Redding and Georgia Harrison and some of the coolest like timeless kind of classic people.
卡姆，我喜欢你挑选了奥蒂斯·雷丁和乔治亚·哈里森以及一些最酷的永恒经典人物。
We didn't always get to, we didn't have enough money to put those ones on every week, but finding that balance between those big ones and then finding cool, smaller stuff, which at the time of December, it's kind of were a little cool and smaller.
我们并不总是能做到这一点，我们没有足够的钱每周都穿上这些衣服，但在这些大衣服和然后找到很酷的小东西之间找到平衡，在十二月的时候，有点酷和小。
Now kind of have like a timeless classic feel to them, but there's something also about what he noticed around needle drops for Ted on these big moments were these swelling kind of classic, you know, classic voices, classic artists.
现在对他们来说有点像永恒的经典感觉，但他在这些重要时刻为泰德的针滴所注意到的还有一些东西是这些膨胀的经典，你知道，经典的声音，经典的艺术家。
I think the thing about Ted that I always tried to hold on to was I Wanted to believe I was playing a character who would age well But both the character would age well and he would literally I wanted him to age well, you know, you know, okay But there's something about using those classic artists as needle drops to signify These big moments were were like almost outside the bounds of time in space.
我认为关于特德，我一直试图坚持的一点是，我想要相信我正在扮演一个会很好地变老的角色，但是两个角色都会很好地变老，他实际上我希望他能够很好地变老，你知道，你知道，好吧，但是使用那些经典艺术家作为针滴来表示这些重大时刻就像几乎超出了空间时间的界限。
They were just yeah Yeah.
他们只是是的。
But Cam's right, the way that Cam took it is so cool, he says that we're in Ted's shoes when we're hearing those songs.
但卡姆是对的，卡姆的处理方式太酷了，他说当我们听到这些歌曲时，我们就站在泰德的立场上。
Cam's feeling is we're in Ted's mind and soul when we're hearing those songs.
卡姆的感觉是，当我们听到这些歌曲时，我们就在特德的思想和灵魂中。
Those are Ted's songs.
这些是特德的歌。
And I like that.
我喜欢这样。
That's cool.
这很酷。
It is a story being told by Future Ted, and somehow these songs in some metaphysical way are part of Future Ted's brain and soul.
这是未来泰德讲述的故事，不知何故，这些歌曲以某种形而上的方式成为未来泰德大脑和灵魂的一部分。
And that's what it said to Cam.
这就是它对卡姆说的。
I kind of love that.
我有点喜欢这样。
I also love where he took it.
我也喜欢他拍摄的地方。
He said, the show taught him it was okay to love things, to okay to double down on them and be dorky, like go really deep into it.
他说，这个节目教会了他热爱事物是可以的，可以加倍努力并变得愚蠢，就像真正深入其中一样。
I mean, I struggled sometimes because I felt like sometimes Ted's enthusiasm was slapped around by the gang.
我的意思是，有时我很挣扎，因为我觉得有时特德的热情被这帮人打垮了。
But it never- At times.
但它从来没有——有时。
Was it Carter was reading like a Teddy Roosevelt biography and then suddenly Ted was obsessed with Teddy Roosevelt?
是不是卡特在读泰迪·罗斯福的传记，然后泰德突然对泰迪·罗斯福着迷了？
Right?
正确的？
Yeah.
是的。
Right, like he was reading those like doorstop books.
是的，就像他正在读那些像门挡书一样的书。
That is absolutely true.
这是绝对正确的。
Carter would proudly admit to it, and Carter was very good at getting very obsessed with something, and it grabbed him, and it had to go on the show.
卡特会自豪地承认这一点，卡特非常擅长对某件事非常着迷，这抓住了他，并且必须在节目中播出。
Often through my character.
经常通过我的性格。
Through your character, yeah.
通过你的性格，是的。
And that was like the catharsis of getting to let go of that move on to the next obsession.
这就像放下执着而转向下一个痴迷的宣泄。
So I'm sure you remember this, because the first couple of seasons, this is back when we were still burning CDs to make mixes for people, which felt like the height of new tech cut against technology.
所以我相信你还记得这一点，因为在前几个赛季中，我们还在刻录 CD 来为人们制作混音，这感觉就像是新技术对技术的顶峰。
I can't believe we can make our own CDVs.
我不敢相信我们可以制造自己的 CDV。
Yeah.
是的。
Nothing's ever going to top this technology.
没有什么能够超越这项技术。
So every couple of weeks, I would burn CDs for the cast.
所以每隔几周，我就会为演员们刻录 CD。
And I think that I know Ali and Kobe really loved it.
我想我知道阿里和科比真的很喜欢它。
I think Jason liked it.
我想杰森喜欢它。
I never knew if Neil liked it, to be honest.
老实说，我从来不知道尼尔是否喜欢它。
But I would give them all an episode.
但我会给他们所有人一集。
What was the one?
那是什么？
Zip, zip, zip.
拉链，拉链，拉链。
Does he make Victoria mixed called Tedscapes?
他让维多利亚混合称为 Tedscapes 吗？
Oh, man.
哦，伙计。
Please fans help us.
请粉丝们帮助我们。
I'm not sure if it's in zip, zip, zip.
我不确定它是否在 zip、zip、zip 中。
I think that's a different thing.
我认为那是另一回事。
There's something called Tedscapes.
有一种东西叫做 Tedscape。
There's definitely Tedscapes, yeah.
肯定有 Tedscape，是的。
My friend Jeremiah is staying at my house.
我的朋友耶利米住在我家。
I still have in Los Angeles.
我还在洛杉矶。
And he was looking for some stuff through the garage and he just sent me a photo of a Tedscapes mix that he found in the garage that I'll send to you.
他正在车库里找东西，他刚刚给我发了一张他在车库里找到的 Tedscapes 混音照片，我会把它发给你。
Maybe we'll maybe.
也许我们会。
And you meaning it was on the show and then you started calling your mixes.
你的意思是它在节目中，然后你开始调用你的混音。
You would make Tedscapes early.
你会很早就制作Tedscapes。
Oh, yeah, yeah.
哦，是啊，是啊。
Tedscapes was on the show And then I called one of the mixes, Tedscapes.
Tedscapes 出现在节目中 然后我将其中一个混音命名为 Tedscapes。
I remember getting handed Tedscapes by you, that was a sweetie.
我记得你递给我 Tedscape，那真是个小可爱。
Yeah, but that was how me, you, Andy, all became like music buddies on the show.
是的，但这就是我、你、安迪在节目中变得像音乐伙伴的原因。
We were just like.
我们就像。
We're music nerds.
我们是音乐迷。
We're about exactly what Camp said.
我们完全按照坎普所说的去做。
And Andy started including me in the music drops.
安迪开始将我纳入音乐中。
He would give you like, once a week, he would give you like a awesome playlist of like new music.
他会给你，每周一次，他会给你一个很棒的新音乐播放列表。
Every episode.
每集。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And you said, I want to be on that chain because I want to hear cool new stuff And that's Andy Gavin's job is to find cool new stuff.
你说，我想加入这个链条，因为我想听到很酷的新东西，而安迪·加文的工作就是寻找很酷的新东西。
And he did it.
他做到了。
Okay, so this episode is also a mystery episode.
好吧，所以这一集也是悬疑剧。
It starts off with a WTF, what's going on?
一开始就WTF，这是怎么回事？
This is crazy, right?
这太疯狂了，对吧？
Give us a little summary of what happens in this episode, Craig.
克雷格，给我们简单介绍一下这一集中发生的事情。
Yeah, this episode is diving into Ted and Robin's early.
是的，这一集深入探讨了泰德和罗宾的早期故事。
It's their first fight, right?
这是他们第一次吵架吧？
This is their first big problem.
这是他们的第一个大问题。
Robin thinks to, Robin doesn't know how to be in a couple.
罗宾想，罗宾不知道如何成为情侣。
and she doesn't want to listen to Ted's work complaints, which of course is a huge part of being in a couple, is being able to complain and be complained too, and it's a two-way complaint street and she just doesn't want to deal with it.
她不想听泰德对工作的抱怨，这当然是夫妻关系的一个重要组成部分，能够抱怨和被抱怨，这是一条双向的抱怨街，她只是不想处理它。
She's kind of phoning in some aspects of what it takes to be in a couple.
她在某些方面是在呼吁情侣之间的关系。
And the journey of the episode is her thinking that Ted has stormed off and is perhaps cheating on her using his hot job as an architect as a way to do that.
这一集的故事情节是，她认为泰德已经怒气冲冲地走了，也许是利用他作为建筑师的热门工作来欺骗她。
And it's, I like the journey for Robin in this one.
我喜欢罗宾在这部电影中的旅程。
She kind of realizes the stakes of being in a relationship and that you do have to go a little crazy.
她有点意识到维持一段关系的风险，并且你确实必须变得有点疯狂。
You do have to be vulnerable.
你确实必须脆弱。
And of course, there's a huge twist to Roo.
当然，Roo 也有一个巨大的转变。
And we read, it's a classic how I met your mother.
我们读到，这是我遇见你母亲的经典。
We see the story twice kind of.
这个故事我们看了两遍。
We see the story one way that Robin's imagining it.
我们以罗宾想象的方式看待这个故事。
And then the real way, which is that Barney is posing his head.
然后是真正的方式，那就是巴尼正在摆出他的头。
And it is, it's a mystery, like many a great how I met your mother episode.
这是一个谜，就像许多精彩的《我是如何遇见你母亲》的剧集一样。
It's remarkable to me in this rewatch How many of these episodes are a little mystery within the larger mystery?
在这次重看中，对我来说很了不起，其中有多少集是更大的谜团中的一个小谜团？
Like every second or third episode is somehow a weird little mystery.
就像每一集或第三集在某种程度上都是一个奇怪的小谜团。
Like what's going on?
好像发生了什么事？
It's also like a time honored narrative technique.
这也像是一种历史悠久的叙事技巧。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, every chapter of Harry Potter ends with like a weird cliffhanger that makes you like absolutely have to turn the page.
你知道，《哈利·波特》的每一章都以一个奇怪的悬念结尾，让你不得不翻过这一页。
Definitely.
确实。
I'm reading it out loud with my daughter right now.
我现在正在和女儿一起大声朗读。
And we got to the cliffhanger and she got so worked up she had to run around the room.
当我们到达悬念时，她非常激动，不得不在房间里跑来跑去。
She just ran around the room.
她只是在房间里跑来跑去。
I said to Rebecca, we were reading it all.
我对丽贝卡说，我们正在读这一切。
We read it as a family.
我们一家人一起读这本书。
We switched off to the voices.
我们关掉声音。
And still he was like, ah!
但他仍然觉得，啊！
Like ran around the room.
就像在房间里跑来跑去。
He was like, oh my God.
他就像，天啊。
I said, Jesus, I want to write something someday that makes someone run around a fucking room.
我说，天哪，我想有一天写一些东西，让人们在一个该死的房间里跑来跑去。
Cause she was, she's nine years old.
因为她是，她九岁了。
She's like, ah, she was running fast.
她就像，啊，她跑得很快。
She just had to throw off the energy.
她只得扔掉能量。
There was just too much.
实在是太多了。
Yeah, she was like, I've got to get this out somehow.
是的，她说，我必须想办法把这件事弄清楚。
She knew she wasn't going to get to go past the cliffhanger.
她知道自己无法跨越这个悬念。
She had to go to bed.
她必须去睡觉了。
I mean, God bless it.
我的意思是，上帝保佑它。
If you can write something that does that kind of create.
如果你能写出一些能创造这种东西的东西。
I immediately said that I said, I don't think I've ever written anything that would make someone run around.
我立刻说，我说，我想我从来没有写过任何会让人跑来跑去的东西。
I did that with your book, Craig.
我对你的书就是这么做的，克雷格。
Thank you, Josh.
谢谢你，乔什。
I kept interrupting the audio recording because I kept running around the booth.
我一直在打断录音，因为我一直在展位周围跑来跑去。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I just realized I saw my friend, you know Michael Cherness, my friend Michael Cherness.
我刚刚意识到我看到了我的朋友，你知道迈克尔·切尔内斯，我的朋友迈克尔·切尔内斯。
He's a great actor, he's on Severance, he was on Origin New Black, he's a long-time friend, we were in drama school at the same time together and he, I saw him in a great play in Fort Green and the gist of the play was this man had died under very strange circumstances and his wife for most of the play doesn't know how to grieve because they were so suspiciously weird and he was with this young college girl and she thinks he was having an affair and the play is done.
他是一个伟大的演员，他在《遣散会》中，他在《起源新黑人》中，他是一个老朋友，我们同时在戏剧学校，他，我在格林堡的一部精彩戏剧中看到了他，该剧的要点是这个男人在非常奇怪的情况下去世了，他的妻子在剧中的大部分时间都不知道如何悲伤，因为他们是如此可疑的奇怪，他和一个年轻的女大学生在一起，她认为他有外遇，而这部剧是完成了。
So I'm not going to even tell you what it is, but the reversal is it turns out he was actually being an extra good guy and someone else was having an affair with her.
所以我什至不会告诉你这是什么，但事实相反，事实证明他实际上是一个特别好的人，而其他人与她有染。
And it's revealed that he was actually like the person she thought he was.
据透露，他实际上就像她想象的那样。
She spends the whole play wondering who was I married to, and then it turns out she was married to the great beautiful kind man that she thought she was married to.
整部剧她都在想我嫁给了谁，结果发现她嫁给了她以为她嫁给的那个伟大、美丽、善良的男人。
And I think that there's a lot, there's a lot of narrative techniques of, oh, the person you thought was good was actually had a heart of darkness.
我认为有很多，有很多叙事技巧，哦，你认为很好的人实际上有一颗黑暗的心。
And it's a journey into their secret life, right?
这是进入他们秘密生活的旅程，对吗？
That's like a trope.
这就像一个比喻。
But there's something nice about that play.
但那场戏有一些不错的地方。
And this one where it's like, no, he's actually who you think he is.
而这就像，不，他实际上就是你认为的那样。
Yeah.
是的。
This was a misunderstanding.
这是一个误会。
This was, you know, so the reveal, of course, is that everyone saying, oh, Ted Mosby architect, he was here.
你知道，所以，当然，每个人都说，哦，特德·莫斯比建筑师，他在这里。
was crazy, and he was seducing everyone.
他很疯狂，他在诱惑所有人。
And it turns out it's Barney wearing the costume of Ted, saying, I'm Ted Mosby, architect, and being Barney, but with this different cloak on.
结果是巴尼穿着泰德的服装，说，我是泰德·莫斯比，建筑师，就是巴尼，但穿着这件不同的斗篷。
Yeah, and it's Robin's willingness to go a little crazy and then realizing that is what it means to be in a relationship.
是的，罗宾愿意变得有点疯狂，然后意识到这就是恋爱关系的意义。
You think you have that other person figured out, he's just gonna come home and complain about work.
你认为你已经了解了另一个人，他只是会回家抱怨工作。
And then it's revealed to you that everyone is a mystery, right?
然后你就会发现每个人都是一个谜，对吗？
She goes down this rabbit hole of like, maybe I don't know this guy at all.
她掉进了这个兔子洞，也许我根本不认识这个人。
And it does turn out to be a complete mislead, but it's a good lesson for her to learn.
事实证明这确实是一个完全的误导，但这对她来说是一个很好的教训。
Like you don't have him figured out.
就像你没有弄清楚他一样。
You don't know everything about Ted.
你并不了解特德的一切。
It's still early days in this.
现在还处于早期阶段。
And not only that, the thought that he might be straying and she might be losing him is really hard for her.
不仅如此，一想到他可能会迷失而她可能会失去他，她真的很难受。
Yeah.
是的。
So it's like, it's almost like you don't know what, it's like cliche, you don't know what you got until it's gone, right?
所以这就像，你几乎不知道什么，就像陈词滥调，你不知道你得到了什么，直到它消失，对吧？
like she starts fantasizing about like, oh, he's going away and I will be bereft and therefore I have to reconceive of who I am in a relationship.
就像她开始幻想，哦，他要走了，我会失去亲人，因此我必须重新构想在一段关系中我是谁。
I think you guys were still really finding the Shurbatski avoid an attachment style.
我认为你们仍然真正发现 Shurbatski 避免了依恋风格。
Like second season feels like you really dialed that in more.
就像第二季感觉你真的投入了更多。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
I think that's the gift of a long-running TV show.
我认为这是长期播出的电视节目的礼物。
You start to peel back the layers and I love she starts the episode off so cocky And so kind of dismissive of, I don't have to do the bullshit of couplehood.
你开始剥开层层，我喜欢她以如此自大和如此轻蔑的方式开始这一集，我不必做夫妻关系的废话。
We'll just get the bullshit part and we'll just do the fun parts.
我们只处理废话部分，只做有趣的部分。
You can't do that.
你不能那样做。
She, you know what I mean?
她，你懂我的意思吗？
She just, that doesn't work.
她只是，那行不通。
And real watching her spiral and become vulnerable.
真实地看着她螺旋式上升并变得脆弱。
I really liked that moment and how Kobe played it where she says, I took the nicest guy in the world and I turned him into a cheater because I was, I took him for granted.
我真的很喜欢那一刻，也很喜欢科比的表现，她说，我选择了世界上最好的人，然后把他变成了一个骗子，因为我把他视为理所当然。
She's wrong about that, but it's important for her to take the hit on that one.
她的想法是错误的，但对她来说，接受这一打击很重要。
And that's, you watch Robin grow in this one.
也就是说，你会看到罗宾在这其中成长。
You watch her learn something in this one, which I like.
你会看到她在这件事上学到了一些东西，我喜欢这一点。
I went to this, these two men's retreats with this group called Every Man, E-V-R-Y-M-A-N.
我和这个名为Every Man, E-V-R-Y-M-A-N 的团体一起去了这两个男人的静修处。
If there are any men out there who are looking for more kind of like to drop into their feelings and lean in more to community, I can't recommend this highly enough.
如果有任何男人正在寻找更多的方式来投入自己的感情并更多地融入社区，我强烈推荐这个。
But this group, it spun off a weekly men's group that I do every Monday night.
但是这个团体，它从我每周一晚上都会做的每周男子团体中分离出来。
And we do this thing called checking in, which I love very much, and Jordana loves it so much that we do it in my marriage, which is essentially you say, Josh, checking in, and you say, you describe what you're feeling physically and sensations.
我们做这件事叫做“检查”，我非常喜欢，乔丹娜也非常喜欢它，所以我们在我的婚姻中这样做，这本质上就是你说，乔什，检查，然后你说，你描述你的身体感受和感觉。
I feel tightness at the top of my shoulders.
我感到肩膀上方紧绷。
I feel a scratchiness of my throat.
我感觉喉咙发痒。
I feel labored breathing.
我感到呼吸困难。
And then you say, any emotions you're feeling.
然后你说，你感受到的任何情绪。
I feel grateful, I feel anxiety.
我感到感激，我感到焦虑。
I feel excitement about tonight.
今晚我感到兴奋。
and I feel thirsty.
我感到口渴。
And then you say, I'm here and I'm in.
然后你说，我在这儿，我在。
And then the other person says, aho, which is like a kind of Native American I'm in.
然后另一个人说，啊哈，这就像我所处的一种美洲原住民。
But we developed something where if you don't really want to check in, all you want to do is complain.
但我们开发了一些东西，如果你真的不想登记，你想做的就是抱怨。
We call it confetching in instead of checking in.
我们称之为“混入”而不是“签入”。
So it was almost like, can I confet in?
所以这就像是，我可以承认吗？
And you say, yeah, you go, I'm annoyed about my haircut.
你说，是的，你走吧，我对我的发型很生气。
I didn't get enough sleep.
我睡眠不足。
And you just, it's a litany of complaints.
而你，只是一连串的抱怨。
And then instead of saying, I'm here and I'm in, you say, I'm here and I'm annoyed.
然后你不是说“我在这里，我在”，而是说，“我在这里，我很生气”。
And then the other person says, achoo, like a sneeze instead of aho.
然后另一个人说“ahoo”，就像打喷嚏而不是“aho”。
This is all like deep marriage, you know, inside joke stuff.
这就像深度婚姻，你知道，内部笑话。
But one, the thing I really love about it is, it's like full permission, like take 30 seconds to a minute and complain.
但我真正喜欢它的一点是，它就像完全的许可，就像花 30 秒到一分钟抱怨一样。
Like you have a runway, complain, tell me what.
就像你有跑道一样，抱怨，告诉我什么。
And I won't try to fix it.
我不会尝试修复它。
But I like that it's limited.
但我喜欢它是有限的。
It's limited, yes.
这是有限的，是的。
That's what's brilliant about that.
这就是它的精彩之处。
Get it out, but don't let it spread.
把它拿出来，但不要让它蔓延。
I think that's what Robin would say yesterday.
我想这就是罗宾昨天会说的话。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
There's another...
还有另一个...
I guess we have...
我想我们有...
I have a real...
我有一个真正的...
I like giving people permission to complain up to a point.
我喜欢在一定程度上允许人们抱怨。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
We should all be cut off.
我们都应该被切断。
There should be a timer on it.
上面应该有一个计时器。
Because the catharsis of it is normal and natural and good.
因为它的宣泄是正常的、自然的、好的。
But have you ever heard that thing in relationships?
但你在人际关系中听说过这句话吗？
when someone comes to you with a problem and you say, do you need a tissue box, a soap box or a toolbox?
当有人向你提出问题，你说，你需要纸巾盒、肥皂盒还是工具箱吗？
No, but that's great.
不，但这很棒。
So it's like tissue box is like, you just wanna like weep and complain.
就像纸巾盒一样，你只想哭泣和抱怨。
I'll give you a tissue box.
我给你一个纸巾盒。
A soap box is you wanna rant and you just wanna rail.
肥皂盒就是你想要咆哮和抱怨的地方。
And a toolbox is do you want help and advice?
工具箱是您需要帮助和建议吗？
It's good, right?
很好，对吧？
It's good.
很好。
Have we turned into a self-help podcast today?
今天我们变成了自助播客吗？
Cause all of this is fucking gold.
因为这一切都是他妈的金子。
I think so.
我想是的。
I love this.
我喜欢这个。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, so it's fascinating to watch Ted and Rod.
是的，看特德和罗德的表演很有趣。
The other thing that relationships, the way you fall in love, we might have talked about this before, the way you fall in love is like, oh my God, she likes the Decemberists.
关系的另一件事，你坠入爱河的方式，我们之前可能已经讨论过，你坠入爱河的方式就像，天哪，她喜欢十二月党人。
I like the Decemberists.
我喜欢十二月党人。
Autumn is her favorite season.
秋天是她最喜欢的季节。
It's my favorite season.
这是我最喜欢的季节。
There's all the like, yes, yes, this lines up, this lines up, we're similar, we're similar, we're similar.
都是这样的，是的，是的，这个排列，这个排列，我们很相似，我们很相似，我们很相似。
It's like nature's way of getting you to fall in love, release those chemicals, the bonding happens, and then one day you're like, oh, we actually have some real differences, you know?
这就像大自然让你坠入爱河的方式，释放这些化学物质，结合发生，然后有一天你会想，哦，我们实际上有一些真正的差异，你知道吗？
And that's when a relationship, that's when you really, I think that's a moment of reckoning where you have to say, do I feel strong enough about this person that I'm going to journey through the valley of these differences and figure out how we can be together?
那是一段关系的时候，那是你真正需要思考的时刻，你必须说，我对这个人的感觉是否足够强大，以至于我将穿越这些差异的山谷，并弄清楚我们如何才能在一起？
Or is this just not, is this gap not bridgeable?
或者这根本不是，这个差距是不可弥合的吗？
And I think they're at, they've been together long enough that they're like at that point of like, oh, they're just hitting that point.
我认为他们已经在一起足够长的时间了，他们就像在那个点上，哦，他们刚刚达到那个点。
Yeah.
是的。
What I like about the end of this episode is that Ted kind of went, first of all, she gives a little.
我喜欢这一集结尾的一点是，泰德有点走了，首先，她付出了一点。
She gives a little.
她给了一点。
She says, I'll listen to you complain.
她说，我会听你抱怨。
She misses him.
她想念他。
She thought she was losing him.
她以为她正在失去他。
She comes to him.
她来到他身边。
She literally comes to him and she has an offering.
她真的来到他身边，并提出了一份奉献。
She has like donuts and coffee.
她喜欢甜甜圈和咖啡。
She comes and is humble.
她来了，而且很谦虚。
But I really like that he switches modes from what I'm complaining about to what I'm excited about.
但我真的很喜欢他把模式从我抱怨的事情转变为我兴奋的事情。
And I think that's something that you can get very stuck in sticking with the relationship So if I'll metaphor here, I feel like the complaining will expand to fill the space given to the complaining.
我认为，在坚持这种关系时，你可能会陷入困境。所以，如果我在这里打个比方，我觉得抱怨会扩大，以填补给予抱怨的空间。
That's why I like the 30 second or the one minute, like the limit.
这就是为什么我喜欢30秒或一分钟，喜欢极限。
And then you also need to offset the complaining by being like, this is what I fucking love.
然后你还需要通过这样的方式来抵消抱怨，这就是我他妈的喜欢的。
When Ted shows her that plan for the building, it's a great ending to that episode because it's like, it really uses the future perspective, the future narrator.
当泰德向她展示该建筑的计划时，这是该集的一个很好的结局，因为它真的使用了未来的视角，未来的叙述者。
Ted isn't such a low point.
特德并不是一个低点的人。
He feels stuck at this terrible job.
他觉得自己被困在这份可怕的工作中。
And yet we get this peak through the narrator that this building's gonna be built.
然而，我们通过叙述者了解到这座建筑即将建成。
Robin's the first person he shows this dream to, and that dream's gonna come true.
罗宾是他向他展示这个梦想的第一个人，而这个梦想将会实现。
I really liked that moment and their connection and that moment.
我真的很喜欢那一刻以及他们的联系和那一刻。
She comes to him with something and he's able to shift gears out of, she says, I'll listen to you complain.
她带着一些东西来找他，他能够摆脱困境，她说，我会听你抱怨。
And he says, no, I don't need that anymore.
他说，不，我不再需要那个了。
Look at my dream.
看看我的梦想。
Maybe someday this will come true and she says, that's beautiful.
也许有一天这会成为现实，她说，那太美了。
It's a great moment at the end of this episode.
这是本集结尾的一个伟大时刻。
It's a great ending scene.
这是一个很棒的结局场景。
Like it could otherwise be kind of a gimmicky.
好像它否则可能是一种噱头。
episode, if not for the way you guys landed the plane.
情节，如果不是因为你们降落飞机的方式。
Like, it really feels like it's, it was quite moving to me that's it.
就像，真的感觉就是这样，这对我来说很感动，就是这样。
It was, I forgot how moving the ending of that episode was.
是的，我忘记了那集的结局是多么感人。
I'd really got me, I really blanked, and I was thinking as I was watching it, like, oh, this one right is kind of a late, farcical episode, and I wanna ask you about what it was like to play that, but like, I, the ending really got me.
我真的明白了，我真的茫然了，我在看的时候就在想，哦，这一集有点迟了，闹剧，我想问你玩这个是什么感觉，但是，我，结局真的让我着迷。
It's Ted's first building.
这是特德的第一座建筑。
It's a huge fucking deal that, it's his first huge career win, And he doesn't know it yet, but we get to know it.
这是他妈的一件大事，这是他职业生涯的第一个巨大胜利，他还不知道，但我们逐渐知道了。
And there's something nice about a traumatic irony of that.
对这一点的创伤性讽刺是有好处的。
And also there's something, I think a very deep lesson in here that even if you're doing what you're passionate about for your career or what you love or what your great talent is, there's still gonna be days of like absolute drudgery, absolute loss of belief in self, loss of belief in the larger kind of, you lose the plot of it.
还有一些事情，我认为这是一个非常深刻的教训，即使你正在做你对职业充满热情的事情，你喜欢的事情，或者你伟大的才能是什么，仍然会有一些日子，就像绝对的苦差事，完全失去对自我的信心，失去对更大的信念的信心，你会失去它的情节。
Same with relationships.
人际关系也一样。
You can be in a great relationship that has rough patches that has, you know, you miss each other sometimes.
你们的关系可能很好，但也会有一些坎坷，你知道，有时你们会想念对方。
And I think that, I think that, how I met your mother was really good about not, I mean, in some ways it's a kind of urban fantasy, but at the same time it was really trying to ground itself in the facts of relationships, but the bumpiness of relationships, the almost impossibility of like communicating with people and then finding a way through it.
我认为，我认为，我如何遇见你母亲真的很好，我的意思是，在某些方面，这是一种都市幻想，但同时它确实试图将自己扎根于关系的事实中，但关系的坎坷，几乎不可能与人交流，然后找到解决办法。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
That's what was so nice about the end of this one.
这就是这个结局的美好之处。
Let me ask you this.
让我问你这个。
What was it like to play the middle of the episode when we're kind of seeing Robin's perception of her fear of what Ted might be that she didn't realize he was or that he's driven him away, she's driven him to this?
在这一集的中间，当我们看到罗宾对她对泰德可能是什么的恐惧的看法时，她没有意识到他是，或者他把他赶走了，她把他逼到了这一步，那感觉怎么样？
I'm always curious, the audience watching this for the first time, did they really buy Ted?
我一直很好奇，第一次看这个的观众，他们真的相信Ted吗？
Was acting that way?
是这样表现的吗？
Did the whole time were you watching it going?
你一直在看着它进行吗？
Something's up here.
这里有东西。
I'm sure there are both reactions.
我确信两种反应都会有。
I would, I would wager you kind of know that there's something up his head is acting so differently.
我敢打赌，你一定知道他脑子里有什么东西表现得如此不同。
Was it fun to lean into playing Barney, playing Ted, but we're seeing your face?
扮演巴尼、泰德是不是很有趣，但我们看到了你的脸？
Like what was that?
就像那是什么？
What was that like to play?
玩起来是什么样的？
I'll tell you this when, when Jordana and I watched it, she was like alarmed.
我会告诉你这一点，当我和乔丹娜观看它时，她感到很震惊。
She was like, what's going on?
她说，这是怎么回事？
Like why is he doing that?
比如他为什么要这么做？
Like she didn't.
就像她没有一样。
This is the, why didn't I think to ask you about Jordana?
这就是，为什么我没想到要问你关于乔丹娜的事？
She bought it.
她买了它。
I think she eventually got ahead of it.
我认为她最终还是领先了。
Like she got on to it.
就像她接受了它一样。
But for a while she was like a little, she was like a little upset.
但有一段时间，她就像是有点，她有点不高兴。
Like what's going on?
好像发生了什么事？
I will say this, I do remember enjoying immensely playing the rake or playing the, like, kind of, because in a series, you know, everyone is given their, like, notes on the keyboard.
我会这么说，我确实记得非常喜欢玩耙子或玩类似的游戏，因为在一个系列中，你知道，每个人都会在键盘上得到他们的类似的音符。
And even though I think Ted was a complicated character, it's like, you're still playing in one-off.
尽管我认为特德是一个复杂的角色，但就像，你仍然在一次性玩。
There's a certain key.
有一定的钥匙。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like a certain key.
就像某个键一样。
It's headspace.
这是顶空。
Yeah.
是的。
So I, whenever I was able to do stuff like whether it was in pineapple, isn't it, you know, where he got to be drunk, anything that gives a little Mr. Hyde to the Dr. Jekyll, I always found it to be really fun because you find yourself hitting those similar notes which you were hired to hit, I knew that I was good and fluent at those notes, I was hired in the band to play that part, but it was fun sometimes when it's like, I don't know, let Ringo sing or like when you mix it up, it feels, it was really fun.
所以我，每当我能够做一些事情，比如是否是在菠萝中，不是吗，你知道，他在哪里喝醉了，任何能给杰基尔博士一点海德先生的东西，我总是觉得这真的很有趣，因为你发现自己击中了你被雇来击中的那些相似的音符，我知道我在这些音符上很好而且很流利，我被雇在乐队里扮演那个角色，但有时当它就像，我不知道，让林戈唱歌或者喜欢当你混起来的时候，感觉，真的很有趣。
And I found it, I remember feeling pretty liberated in it.
我发现了它，我记得在其中感到非常自由。
It's almost like playing a villain can be really fun.
就好像扮演一个恶棍真的很有趣。
It's like, it's just fun, it's fun to play.
就像，这很有趣，玩起来很有趣。
And I think Neil had a blast with this for nine straight years.
我认为尼尔连续九年都对此感到高兴。
Like, it's fun to play socially unacceptable things like in a fictional context, where you then get to go home to your normal life and have dinner afterwards.
比如，在虚构的环境中玩社会上不可接受的事情很有趣，然后你就可以回家过正常的生活，然后吃晚饭。
And like no one's, you don't get the consequence, you get applause.
与任何人不同的是，你没有得到结果，你得到的是掌声。
You know?
你知道？
It's funny how the moments you got to do that kind of thing, the Ted got to do that kind of thing, even though this was kind of a fantasy, he wasn't really doing this.
有趣的是，当你要做那种事情的时候，特德也要做那种事情，尽管这有点幻想，但他并没有真正这样做。
It's always, it makes you lean forward a little bit.
它总是会让你向前倾一点。
It's good to keep the audience a little on their toes and be like, what's happening here?
让观众保持警惕是件好事，他们会问，这里发生了什么？
And just see another side of you as an actor.
看看你作为演员的另一面。
And then conversely with Neil as Barney, when you saw a little flicker of humanity and warmth from Barney, it was really interesting.
相反，尼尔饰演巴尼，当你看到巴尼身上闪烁着一点人性和温暖时，真的很有趣。
It was always, those little opposite grace that the Dr. Declan Mr. Hyde, that you want to see that other side of the coin sometimes.
德克兰博士海德先生的那种相反的优雅，总是让你有时想看到硬币的另一面。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's powerful.
而且它很强大。
Isn't it also, and I think they've done studies, the reason that like deep fakes are so concerning is because if you see one, it imprints upon you, whether it's true or not, let's just call it untrue.
我认为他们已经做过研究，难道深度赝品之所以如此令人担忧，是因为如果你看到一个，它就会在你身上留下印记，无论它是真是假，我们就称它为不真实吧。
It's a deep, it's a deep fake.
这是一个深，这是一个深假。
You know, they, politicians saying something they never said.
你知道，他们政客说了一些他们从未说过的话。
And then when you, when it's been revealed, this was actually doctored.
然后，当它被揭露时，这实际上是被篡改的。
This was, you go, oh, that wasn't real, but something of it.
这是，你去，哦，那不是真的，但有一些。
Yeah, you still have the memory.
是的，你还有记忆。
You still, it's like as if you saw it, right?
你还是，就像亲眼所见一样，对吧？
Like your, your reptilian brain is like, no, no, no, I saw that happen then.
就像你一样，你的爬行动物大脑就像，不，不，不，我当时就看到了这种情况。
That's true.
这是真的。
I saw the shocking thing coming out of this person's mouth and it changed my perception of them.
我看到这个人嘴里说出的令人震惊的话，改变了我对他们的看法。
That's what this episode kind of is in Robin's brain.
这就是罗宾脑子里这一集的内容。
It's kind of what's happening.
这就是正在发生的事情。
And in some ways, Ted, for both the viewer and for Robin, It's like forever changed a little bit.
在某些方面，特德，对于观众和罗宾来说，这就像永远改变了一点点。
Like the idea that like, well, he didn't actually do those things, but he's capable of them.
就像这样的想法，好吧，他实际上没有做这些事情，但他有能力做到这些。
Or did he do that?
或者他确实这么做了？
Like I think I saw him do them.
就像我想我看到他做的那样。
I imagine him doing them.
我想象他正在做这些事。
Other people reported he did them.
其他人报告说是他干的。
Yeah, it's fascinating.
是的，这很有趣。
It's one thing that really I find unnerving about the future we're throttling towards.
对于我们正在努力实现的未来，我确实感到不安的一件事。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
I hate it so much.
我非常讨厌它。
It's so bad.
太糟糕了。
Obviously this episode moves very quickly.
显然这一集进展得很快。
And am I right in saying there is no B story.
我说的对吗？没有B故事。
There are sort of two sides to the A store.
A 店有两个侧面。
Yeah, and that's true of a lot of really good Hemium episodes.
是的，很多非常精彩的 Hemium 剧集都是如此。
There's not quite a B store, there's kind of things to play along the way.
不完全是B店，一路上也有一些可以玩的东西。
And I really like lilies in this, but you're right, everyone's kind of on the same train.
我真的很喜欢这里的百合花，但你是对的，每个人都在同一列火车上。
There's one train creating the momentum, and then there's these little things going on for people that are on that one train.
一列火车创造了动力，然后那一列火车上的人们就会发生一些小事情。
Lilies I liked a lot, because Lilies was Robin, I'm teaching you about what it takes to be in a relationship, the sacrifices, the listening to the complaints.
我很喜欢莉莉丝，因为莉莉丝是罗宾，我正在教你如何建立一段关系，牺牲，倾听抱怨。
And I know this and I don't want to see you fuck it up because I really miss Marshall and I lost that.
我知道这一点，我不想看到你搞砸了，因为我真的很想念马歇尔，但我失去了它。
And now I wish I had that back.
现在我希望能找回那个。
So don't lose it.
所以不要丢失它。
That was a good angle for Lilly.
对于莉莉来说，这是一个很好的角度。
And that's kind of enough.
这就足够了。
It's a 22 minute thing.
这是22分钟的事情。
Sometimes when we did A story, B story, C stories or D story, it gets so hard to keep all those plates spinning.
有时，当我们制作 A 故事、B 故事、C 故事或 D 故事时，很难让所有这些板块保持运转。
When you find these ideas where everything is on that one train and there's one main thing, it's kind of great.
当你发现所有东西都在一列火车上并且只有一件主要事情的想法时，这真是太棒了。
And this one had that momentum.
而这个就有这样的动力。
Yeah, I always like, I think Alison's very good at being like relationship Yoda.
是的，我一直喜欢，我认为艾莉森非常擅长像关系尤达一样。
Yeah, but she's bruised as she's doing it.
是的，但她这样做时受伤了。
She's lost Marshall and I liked that so much in this one.
她失去了马歇尔，我非常喜欢这一点。
And it kind of catches Robin's attention when she says, Hey, I wish I had this right now.
当罗宾说“嘿，我希望我现在就拥有这个”时，这引起了罗宾的注意。
Yeah, what I wouldn't give.
是的，我不会给的。
Yeah, I did think it was a funny runner of Marshall thinking, oh, my law school classmates are gonna be I was so devastated by the work of this great guy.
是的，我确实认为这是马歇尔的一个有趣的跑步者思考，哦，我的法学院同学会是我对这个伟大人物的工作感到非常震惊。
But you know, I had this in my 20s.
但你知道，我20多岁的时候就有过这个经历。
I had a three year relationship with this wonderful woman.
我和这个美妙的女人有过三年的关系。
And I somehow, because it was my first like, very big long-term relationship, I thought everyone was very invested in us being together and staying together, very invested.
不知何故，因为这是我第一次非常大的长期关系，我认为每个人都对我们在一起并待在一起非常投入，非常投入。
You know?
你知道？
This is the glue holding the universe together.
这是将宇宙粘合在一起的粘合剂。
Yeah, at least, at least the west side of Los Angeles.
是的，至少，至少在洛杉矶西侧。
I thought they need us to be together.
我以为他们需要我们在一起。
And when we broke up, I had this thing, what are our friends gonna think this is?
当我们分手时，我有了这个东西，我们的朋友会认为这是什么？
How do I break this news?
我该如何发布这个消息？
When I tell you that no one was shocked and no one was particularly thrown, everyone was like, yeah, I kind of saw that.
当我告诉你，没有人感到震惊，也没有人特别震惊时，每个人都会说，是的，我看到了这一点。
I didn't think you guys would.
我没想到你们会这么做。
Do you wanna play tennis?
你想打网球吗？
Like, no one had a problem with it.
就像，没有人对此有任何问题。
And it was just a reminder of how we naturally center ourselves.
这只是提醒我们如何自然地集中自己。
Yes, Marshall was in his own.
是的，马歇尔独自一人。
He's just like the main character.
他就像主角一样。
And he's the main character, him and Lily, were the glue that was holding this law school class together, this Columbia law school class was like, needed Lily and Marshall to be together.
他是主角，他和莉莉，是将这个法学院班级凝聚在一起的粘合剂，这个哥伦比亚法学院班级就像是，需要莉莉和马歇尔在一起。
And it's, yeah.
是的。
He even says like, we're the couple that made you all believe in love.
他甚至说，我们是让你们都相信爱情的情侣。
And I'm just like, what?
我只是想，什么？
But back actually pointed out, watching it again, she's like, shouldn't Brad have said like, hey, Lily, what's up?
但回来实际上指出，再看一遍，她想，布拉德不应该说，嘿，莉莉，怎么了？
Cause Lily comes knocking and it's Brad and she's, all those people are supposed to know her and stuff.
因为莉莉来敲门，是布拉德和她，所有这些人都应该认识她之类的。
And no one really acknowledges her.
而没有人真正承认她。
It kind of felt like an error.
这感觉就像是一个错误。
Like if I could go back, I think I would have had Brad be like, hey, Lily's heard about the breakup.
就像如果我可以回去一样，我想我会让布拉德说，嘿，莉莉听说了分手的事。
Like some acknowledgement, I don't know.
就像一些承认一样，我不知道。
Maybe we had that in the script or shot it and cut it and added because we were always so overly long.
也许我们在剧本里有这样的内容，或者拍摄它、剪辑它并添加它，因为我们总是太长。
But it was a good point.
但这是一个好点。
It was like, that was a little bit of a blooper.
就好像，这有点花哨。
It almost felt like someone should have just been like, hey, Lily, you're a marshaller both here.
几乎感觉就像有人应该说，嘿，莉莉，你们都是这里的编组员。
Is that okay?
可以吗？
Like some, some little moment like that probably should have been in there.
像某些人一样，这样的小时刻可能应该存在于其中。
I like to do me a couple of us as we go and just own some of these.
我喜欢在我们去的时候给我做几个，然后只拥有其中的一些。
Some of them are we offended a marginalized community and otherwise other ones are but we made a narrative misstep.
其中一些是我们冒犯了边缘化社区，而另一些则是我们犯了叙事失误。
Heh heh heh.
呵呵呵呵。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
这位老人，他强迫我，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I loved the law school party and I thought, again, you guys were finding really funny ways to flash forward.
我喜欢法学院的聚会，我想，你们又找到了非常有趣的方式来闪现。
And pressing it.
并按下它。
It felt like there's, it's almost like a Brett Kavanaugh joke in there.
感觉就像是，这几乎就像布雷特·卡瓦诺的笑话一样。
Not to get too political.
不要太政治化。
Yes.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
This very debauched dude who's super, you know, he's going to get in the future.
这个非常放荡的家伙，他是超级的，你知道，他将来会得到的。
This will be a Supreme Court justice.
这将是最高法院的法官。
And he'll have some stories from his party days or whatever the fuck.
他还会讲一些聚会时的故事或者其他什么鬼故事。
So that was, I enjoyed that.
就是这样，我很享受。
I enjoyed this little flash forward.
我很喜欢这个小闪进。
There's a couple of good little narrator flash forwards in this one.
这其中有几个不错的小旁白快闪。
I like the narrator was nicely present in this future Ted.
我喜欢叙述者在未来的特德身上表现得很好。
I liked, you know, I think the first time you see that guy, he's saying, who wants to shave my ass, right?
我喜欢，你知道，我想你第一次见到那个家伙时，他会说，谁想刮我的屁股，对吧？
And then like a cut to you a couple hours earlier, we're going to shave of your ass and he's like, no way, no, what is it?
然后就像几个小时前对你的割伤一样，我们要剃掉你的屁股，他说，不可能，不，这是什么？
The wording of it is, is Joe Manganela's character says, hey, you should let us shave your ass tonight, which is the fucking weirdest.
它的措辞是，乔·曼加内拉扮演的角色说，嘿，你应该让我们今晚给你剃屁股，这真是最奇怪的了。
Like he's really, he really wants to.
就像他真的一样，他真的很想这么做。
He's just, he's gonna be disappointed if it doesn't happen.
他只是，如果这件事没有发生，他会感到失望。
Why does Brad want to shave this guy's ass that bad?
为什么布拉德这么想把这家伙的屁股剃光？
I mean, Brad, there's nothing, I saw a thing someone said, Jack Black is the only person who needs no context.
我的意思是，布拉德，没什么，我看到有人说过，杰克·布莱克是唯一不需要背景的人。
Like if you're like, Jack Black in moon boots, walking down San Vicente Boulevard playing whatever song, you'd be like, that tracks.
就像如果你像杰克·布莱克一样，穿着月亮靴，沿着圣维森特大道行走，播放任何你喜欢的歌曲。
Like I think Brad is a little like, he can say whatever.
就像我认为布拉德有点像，他可以说什么。
He can just say that, yeah.
他只能这么说，是的。
He wants to, that's what he's waiting for at that party is gonna have to happen.
他想，这就是他在聚会上等待的事情一定会发生。
He knows it's gonna happen.
他知道这会发生。
The other funny thing is like, when you reverse engineer a joke like that, so you see this guy at the end, again, like it's very hymium thing, like, who wants to shave my ass?
另一个有趣的事情是，当你对这样的笑话进行逆向工程时，你会在最后看到这个家伙，再次，就像这是非常谦虚的事情，就像，谁想刮我的屁股？
And then three hours earlier, he was like under no circumstances.
三小时前，他就像在任何情况下一样。
Will anyone be shaving my ass?
有人会帮我刮屁股吗？
Yeah, no.
是的，不。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
I'm not gonna do that.
我不会那样做。
It allows your brain, this is the fun hymium thing.
它可以让你的大脑兴奋起来，这就是有趣的事情。
It tickles your brain, because you go, what happened in the last three hours that he went from absolutely not to 100% you should do this?
这会让你的大脑发痒，因为你会想，在过去的三个小时里发生了什么，他从绝对不会变成100%你应该这样做？
Yes, all in, running into the room.
是的，全力以赴，跑进房间。
It really gives it like a, I call it like a Hirschfeld drawing, you know, where I use this metaphor in writing a lot when I go right.
它确实给人一种，我称之为赫希菲尔德画作，你知道，当我往右走时，我在写作中经常使用这个比喻。
I'll say, no, this two are written, like just a couple lines to suggest.
我会说，不，这两句话都是写的，就像几行建议一样。
Like just zzzzzzzzzz.
就像 zzzzzzzzzz 一样。
And then you've got the whole world.
然后你就拥有了整个世界。
That to me is like a Hirschfeld drawing joke.
对我来说，这就像赫希菲尔德的一个绘画笑话。
It's like, yeah, yeah.
就像，是啊，是啊。
And trusting the audience to follow a backwards joke like that.
并相信观众会听懂这样一个倒退的笑话。
That's a joke told in reverse.
这是一个反过来讲的笑话。
And yeah, this exhibited a bunch of like, himium strengths this episode.
是的，这一集展示了很多类似的优点。
How about the field of dream talk that Robbins go to horrible movies, is real good dreams.
梦境怎么样，罗宾斯去看恐怖电影，是真正的好梦。
And then they're able to, you didn't even watch the whole thing, which is, which, it, let's her off a hook a little bit.
然后他们就可以，你甚至没有看到整个事情，这，这，这，让她稍微摆脱困境。
Alec is holding up his DVD of Field of Dreams.
亚历克正举着他的《梦想之地》DVD。
No, I'm holding up a VHS tape.
不，我拿着一盘 VHS 录像带。
Wow.
哇。
A Field of Dreams, the, the first or perhaps second movie my, my father bought for me.
《梦想之地》是我父亲给我买的第一部电影，也许是第二部电影。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
We are just down the center of the barrel bullseye, father, son, watching Field of Dreams, bought me my Field of Dreams here.
我们就在桶靶心的中心，父亲和儿子正在观看《梦想之地》，在这里给我买了《梦想之地》。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah.
是的。
So the excellent, excellent choice.
所以这是非常非常非常好的选择。
Say it, say it, say it.
说吧，说吧，说吧。
I often do, uh, over the years, I've, you know, and people say, do you love Star Wars?
我经常这样做，呃，多年来，我，你知道，人们说，你喜欢星球大战吗？
And I'm like, no, like, no, not like that, like, like I'm always trying to distance myself from Ted.
我就像，不，就像，不，不是那样，就像，就像我总是试图与特德保持距离。
Yeah.
是的。
But let me say this.
但让我说一下。
Yeah.
是的。
Field of fucking dreams is one of the greatest.
他妈的梦想领域是最伟大的领域之一。
I saw that movie opening weekend.
我看了那部电影的首映周末。
Yeah.
是的。
I was in high school.
我当时在读高中。
Yeah.
是的。
I started opening week with some friends.
我和一些朋友开始了开放周。
so bold over by that movie that I rounded up another group of friends to go back with me the next night.
那部电影是如此大胆，以至于我第二天晚上又召集了另一群朋友和我一起回去。
I saw it Friday night and Saturday night opening weekend.
我在周五晚上和周六晚上的周末开幕时看到了它。
Yeah.
是的。
I've only done that with one other movie.
我只在另一部电影中这样做过。
I mean, I really was, I continue, I showed Jordan that movie recently.
我的意思是，我确实是，我继续说，我最近给乔丹看了那部电影。
She hadn't seen it.
她没有看到。
And it's just one for the ages.
这只是一个永恒的话题。
It absolutely holds up.
它绝对站得住脚。
And it's, yeah, every part of it, I think, is pretty perfect.
是的，我认为它的每个部分都非常完美。
When I watched the movie, I go, and I know it's a book first, and I never read the book.
当我看电影的时候，我去了，我首先知道这是一本书，但我从来没有读过这本书。
I got to go read the book, which is weird, because we both adore this movie.
我必须去看这本书，这很奇怪，因为我们都喜欢这部电影。
All adored, so did you read the book, Alec?
都很喜欢，所以你读过这本书吗，亚历克？
It's funny.
很有趣。
Yeah, it's very different, right?
是的，这是非常不同的，对吧？
I've heard it's very different.
我听说这是非常不同的。
It's got, I mean, yeah.
我的意思是，是的。
Why not read it?
为什么不读呢？
Yeah, I just got read an hour and a half.
是啊，我才读了一个半小时。
But what a genius idea.
但这真是一个天才的想法。
That's a movie I watch.
这是我看的一部电影。
I just go like, I just wish I could have thought.
我只是想，我只是希望我能思考。
Like, how do you get to that idea?
比如，你是如何想到这个想法的？
How do you think of that idea?
你觉得这个主意怎么样？
And then thread the needle on the idea, like ghost baseball players in a corn field.
然后将这个想法付诸实践，就像玉米地里的幽灵棒球运动员一样。
And it becomes the most poignant study in fatherhood and being a son and a father like it it has the high concept and it's so much sticks the landing on what the emotional underpinning is under the high concept it's just it's a work of genius.
它成为关于父亲身份、作为一个儿子和一个父亲的最令人心酸的研究，它有很高的概念，它是如此贴近高概念下的情感基础，它只是一部天才的作品。
Oh I want to say this Phil Alden Robinson who wrote and directed that movie he reached out to us and sent us a little card thanking us for like referencing the guys love the movie I may even have that somewhere still he he sent us a little handwritten note.
哦，我想说的是，编剧和导演那部电影的菲尔·奥尔登·罗宾逊联系了我们，给我们发了一张小卡片，感谢我们喜欢引用那些喜欢这部电影的人，我什至可能还在某个地方，他给我们发了一张手写的小纸条。
I was like, I saw this on your show.
我当时想，我在你的节目中看到了这个。
And it was like, I would bloom my fucking mind because it was season two.
就好像，我他妈的会开开心心的，因为这是第二季。
The show wasn't a hit yet.
该剧还没有大受欢迎。
It was still that thing of like, right, people watch this on TV.
仍然是这样的事情，对吧，人们在电视上看这个。
And one of them might be the guy who did fucking field of dreams.
其中之一可能就是那个他妈的梦想之地的人。
He might end up seeing this.
他最终可能会看到这一点。
Well, it's nice to have such a big platform to shout out things you love and to reference it.
嗯，很高兴有这么大的平台来大声说出你喜欢的东西并引用它。
It's also funny that even though these characters were a little younger than us, so like three or four years younger than us.
同样有趣的是，尽管这些角色比我们年轻一点，大约比我们小三四岁。
Yeah.
是的。
It's solidly like a late Gen X cultural reference show, right?
这真的很像已故的 X 世代文化参考节目，对吧？
It is like that's the cultural barrel we were kind of pulling from.
这就像我们从中汲取的文化桶。
I find emotionally with just one more field of dreams, which is it's now, it's, it's how much before the event I start crying now, now that I know it's coming.
我发现在情感上我又多了一个梦想，就是现在，就是，距离我开始哭泣的事件还有多久，现在我知道它即将到来。
I don't have to wait for him to say, do you want to have a catch?
我不用等他说，你想钓吗？
Oh, my God, I'm 30 seconds ahead of it going, this is going to happen again.
天哪，我提前了 30 秒，这种事又要发生了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's not just gonna hit me again, it hit me now instead.
它不仅会再次打击我，而且现在会打击我。
I feel like I'm choked up right at the moment.
我感觉我此刻已经哽咽了。
Yeah, the score is perfect.
是的，成绩很完美。
Oh, the music in that movie, see it all comes back to music, full circle cam.
哦，那部电影中的音乐，一切都回到了音乐，完整的循环凸轮。
And also there's that kind of like beautiful but slightly ominous like a thing that kind of announces like something strange is about to happen and mystical.
还有一种美丽但有点不祥的东西，就像某种奇怪的事情即将发生一样，而且很神秘。
Yeah, resonating.
是的，有共鸣。
Oh my God, beautifully shot, beautifully designed.
天哪，拍摄精美，设计精美。
Josh, I don't know if you also grew up with it with a heavy dose of J.D.
乔什，我不知道你是否也伴随着大量的 J.D. 长大。
Salinger.
塞林格。
I know Craig and I did.
我认识克雷格，我也认识。
Okay, so Field of Dreams is based on Shulis Jo by W.P.
好的，《Field of Dreams》是根据 W.P. 的 Shulis Jo 改编的。
Kinsella.
金塞拉。
And the main character's name is Ray Kinsella.
主角的名字叫雷·金塞拉。
In Shulis Jo, they actually go and seek out J.D.
在 Shulis Jo 中，他们实际上是去寻找 J.D.
Salinger.
塞林格。
They don't change the name to Terence Mann.
他们没有把名字改成特伦斯·曼。
It is J.D.
这是 J.D.
Salinger in the book.
塞林格在书中。
Okay.
好的。
And in Catcher and the Rye, one of Holden's classmates' names, last name is Kinsella.
在《守望者与麦田》中，霍尔顿的同学之一的姓氏是金塞拉。
Boy, that's crazy.
男孩，这太疯狂了。
Yeah, so it twists it on itself, Hemiums.
是的，所以它本身就扭曲了，Hemiums。
And Terrence Mann is a Broadway actor who was the original Javere in Les Mis on Broadway.
泰伦斯·曼 (Terrence Mann) 是一位百老汇演员，他是百老汇《悲惨世界》中的原版贾维尔。
Yes, the simulation is officially glitching out.
是的，模拟正式出现故障。
I don't even know what's real anymore.
我什至不知道什么是真实的了。
Wow, well, getting it back to how I met your mother, I love that movie, for whatever reason, is like Kryptonite for men's kind of stoicism, right?
哇，好吧，回到我是如何认识你母亲的，我喜欢那部电影，无论出于什么原因，就像氪石对于男人的斯多葛主义一样，对吧？
Like even Barney, who has so much invested and a mask of imperturbability is just loud.
就连巴尼也一样，他投入了如此多的精力，却一副镇定自若的样子，声音很大。
He's undone by the thought of the movie.
一想到这部电影，他就崩溃了。
You guys, the outrage that she hit, when the little cuts back and forth of the flashback of Robin's, she doesn't like it, and the cuts back and forth to you guys at the bar, you guys were so fucking funny in that, the three of you, the outrage and then the crying.
你们，她所受到的愤怒，当罗宾的闪回的小镜头来回切换时，她不喜欢它，而酒吧里的你们来回切换，你们太他妈有趣了，你们三个，愤怒，然后哭泣。
It's just a little journey there, it's the best.
这只是一个小小的旅程，这是最好的。
Yeah.
是的。
That was a no acting required.
那是不需要表演的。
Like, like, like, I genuinely, if I showed, like, I mean, like, what if I showed Jordana Field of Dreams?
就像，就像，就像，我真的，如果我展示，就像，我的意思是，如果我展示乔丹娜梦想之地会怎样？
It didn't land on her.
它没有落在她身上。
Well, that would be like, on the future episode, this, the, the trilogy, the whole, uh, Stella of it all.
嗯，就像，在未来的剧集中，这个，那个，三部曲，整个，呃，斯特拉这一切。
And Stella doesn't like Star Wars later.
而且斯黛拉后来也不喜欢星球大战了。
You would have been living a version of what happened.
你可能会经历所发生事情的一个版本。
This is so, so much further down the line, but I still remember watching Sarah chalk watch Star Wars, worse, which is such a funny visual.
事情就是如此，如此之远，但我仍然记得看着莎拉粉笔观看《星球大战》，更糟糕的是，这是一个非常有趣的视觉效果。
She's trying to watch it and he's just zeroed in on her.
她正想看，而他却把注意力集中在她身上。
He's not watching the screen at all.
他根本没有看屏幕。
That was you with Field of Dreams with Jordana, and she liked it.
那是你和乔丹娜一起出演《梦想之地》，她很喜欢。
The good news is she liked it.
好消息是她喜欢它。
I hadn't seen it in quite a while.
我已经好久没看到它了。
I don't know.
我不知道。
There are certain movies that each frame lives in your bloodstream.
有些电影的每一帧都存在于你的血液中。
You just know the movie that well.
你对这部电影太了解了。
And that tootsie is like that for me or broadcast news like I just I know them so well that there's there's almost pleasure they you know we talked about this like the psychological pleasure in returning to a show over and over is in a chaotic world full of unknowns and unpredictability you actually there's something it's calms our nervous system to know oh I know what's going to happen in this episode I know that Ted isn't cheating on Robin I know it's Barney oh I'm so relieved I'm so relaxed by this you know?
那个tootsie对我来说就是这样，或者像我一样广播新闻，我只是太了解他们了，他们几乎很高兴你知道我们谈论过这个，就像一遍又一遍地回到节目中的心理愉悦是在一个充满未知和不可预测的混乱世界中你实际上有一些东西可以让我们的神经系统平静下来哦我知道这一集中会发生什么我知道泰德没有欺骗罗宾我知道这是巴尼哦我是我松了口气，你知道吗？
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
It makes sense that Ted loves Field of Dreams, too, doesn't it?
泰德也喜欢《梦想之地》，这是有道理的，不是吗？
Oh, 100%.
哦，100%。
It's a dreamers act to build that, to cut away the corn and build, it's almost architect-like to create this baseball field in the corn crop.
这是一个梦想家的行为，要砍掉玉米并建造，这几乎就像建筑师一样在玉米作物中建造这个棒球场。
It's a very like, and everyone thinks he's crazy.
非常像，每个人都认为他疯了。
It's like Ted's rain dance side of him.
这就像特德雨舞的一面。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
There's actually similar.
其实还有类似的
And he also ultimately just wants to connect with his dad.
他最终也只是想与他的父亲联系。
He's just hurting.
他只是受伤了。
And the universe wants that apparently, too, in the world of Field of Dreams, the universe is conspiring to reconnect them.
显然，宇宙也希望如此，在《梦境》的世界中，宇宙正在密谋将它们重新连接起来。
It's so great.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay, I'm going to go watch it right now.
好的，我现在就去看。
The three of you guys are really funny in this one.
你们三个在这一部里真的很有趣。
Like, it's just kicked off with that Field of Dreams thing.
就像，它刚刚从《梦想之地》的事情开始。
I really enjoy the three of you guys in this one.
我真的很喜欢你们三个。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, there was something about when it would be Ted Marshall and Barney, and we could not be adversarial, but be kind of on the same page together that I always found very pleasing to play.
是的，有一些关于什么时候是泰德·马歇尔和巴尼的事情，我们不能是敌对的，而是要在同一页面上在一起，我总是觉得玩起来很愉快。
I love the speechless cutaway when I was like, here's what Robin said, dissing field of dreams.
我喜欢无言的切角，当时我就像罗宾所说的那样，嘲笑梦想的领域。
You just cut and they're just like They're beyond it's beyond the ability to speak how outraged they are.
你只要剪掉，他们就好像他们无法表达他们有多么愤怒。
Yeah And also when there was it when there was something required of like a kind of big silent reaction, right?
是的，当需要某种大的无声反应时，对吧？
Like Jason would be doing Jason's version of that and Neil would be doing Neil's version of that And it was always like how like what is tech like if you're creating a symphony, you can't all be doing the same thing So it's kind of like, well, we're, oh no, it might be nice for the oboe to come in here right now or something like, you're always trying to figure out what's the funniest kind of trio language.
就像杰森会做杰森的版本，尼尔会做尼尔的版本，这总是就像如果你在创作一首交响乐，科技就像什么，你们不可能都做同样的事情所以这有点像，好吧，我们，哦不，现在双簧管进来可能会很好或者类似的东西，你总是试图找出最有趣的三重奏语言。
Yeah, Lily even says explicitly, I feel like I'm teaching love as a second language.
是的，莉莉甚至明确地说，我觉得我正在把爱作为第二语言来教授。
Yeah, that's her bit.
是的，这就是她的一点。
That's her bit in this one.
这就是她在这其中的部分。
It's always nice to sort of name the bit and like, all right, this is the game we're playing.
给这个点命名总是很好的，就像，好吧，这就是我们正在玩的游戏。
This is the book you're saying?
你说的是这本书？
Yeah.
是的。
I love those Supreme Court justices.
我爱那些最高法院的法官。
That's our attorney general.
那是我们的司法部长。
Yeah.
是的。
I love when Ted says, I'm going to design a cathedral and I take a whack at the whole God-man thing.
我喜欢泰德说，我要设计一座大教堂，我对整个神人事物进行了猛烈的打击。
The God-man conundrum, maybe?
也许是神人难题？
Or maybe that was God-man conundrum.
或许这就是神人难题。
Was that fake Ted?
那是假特德吗？
Was that actually Barney who said that?
这真的是巴尼说的吗？
That's fake, that's Faz Barney.
那是假的，那是法兹·巴尼。
Yeah, I guess this is verbatim.
是的，我想这是逐字逐句的。
The bullshit Barney was spewing is what, yeah.
巴尼吐出的废话就是这样，是的。
Yeah, dancing leads to sex.
是的，跳舞会带来性。
And who says, did you grew up in that Footloose Town?
谁说你是在那个自由自在的小镇长大的？
Was that Lily, who says that?
说这话的是莉莉吗？
Yeah, that was Lily.
是的，那是莉莉。
And this is also a flash forward.
这也是一个闪进。
One of my all-time favorite how I met your mother jokes is when John Lithgow was on the show and he was dancing and someone tried to get, oh Barney tried to get him stop.
我最喜欢的关于我遇见你母亲的笑话之一是当约翰·利思戈在节目中时，他正在跳舞，有人试图阻止，哦巴尼试图让他停下来。
And he said, oh, I'm sorry, a small town preacher.
他说，哦，对不起，一个小镇传教士。
Is it illegal to dance here?
在这里跳舞违法吗？
It's funny because I was going to say I think we did multiple foot loose references that were essentially that joke and it may be from me because I feel like I make foot loose town jokes quite a bit.
这很有趣，因为我想说我认为我们做了很多关于脚放松的参考，这些基本上就是那个笑话，它可能来自我，因为我觉得我经常开玩笑。
Yeah.
是的。
Remember we used to talk about like when a guest star would be on the show and it'd be like do they not know who John Lithgow is like have they never seen why aren't they like Barney's dad looks just like John Lithgow.
还记得我们曾经谈论过客串明星出现在节目中，就像他们不知道约翰·利思戈是谁一样，他们从来没有见过为什么他们不喜欢巴尼的父亲看起来就像约翰·利思戈一样。
Yeah, I guess John let's go doesn't exist in that him universe because he would he looks other.
是的，我猜约翰让我们走在他的宇宙中不存在，因为他会看起来不一样。
So like Maury Povich exists.
就像莫里·波维奇一样存在。
Yeah, Maury Povich exists.
是的，莫里·波维奇存在。
Regis Philbin exists.
瑞吉斯·菲尔宾存在。
I guess just daytime talk show hosts.
我想只是白天脱口秀主持人。
That's it.
就是这样。
Oh, I thought it was funny how Barney explained why he did this because he had some recent bad press on the world wide web the world wide web.
哦，我觉得巴尼解释他这样做的原因很有趣，因为他最近在万维网上有一些负面报道。
Right.
正确的。
I mean, one, just the way he describes it is funny.
我的意思是，一，他描述的方式很有趣。
But two, it's It's like, oh, he was getting canceled before cancellation.
但第二，这就像，哦，他在取消之前就被取消了。
Yeah, yeah, there was a lot of pressure in moments in this one.
是的，是的，这一刻压力很大。
Like word was starting to spread, stay away from this guy.
就像消息开始传播一样，远离这个家伙。
Yeah, he had to change his name briefly until it blew over.
是的，他不得不短暂地改变自己的名字，直到事情平息为止。
Yeah, I think it's funny how they go in.
是的，我觉得他们进去的方式很有趣。
And like Barney's just like casually handcuffed the woman's in the shower.
就像巴尼一样，在淋浴时随意地给女人戴上手铐。
Yeah, what was his plan there?
是啊，他在那里有什么计划？
What was going to happen?
将会发生什么？
He's gotten one arm out.
他伸出了一只手臂。
He presumed that one of those, the other arm, both arms were done and he's gotten one arm out, I think.
他认为其中一只，另一只手臂，两只手臂都已经完成，我想他已经取出了一只手臂。
Yeah.
是的。
And also it was like, was she showering because of something they had just done or showering in anticipation of something they were about to do?
而且就像，她是因为他们刚刚做的事情而洗澡，还是因为期待他们即将要做的事情而洗澡？
That's a big question.
这是一个大问题。
We're not going to answer that one.
我们不会回答这个问题。
That's an unsolved, how I met your mother mystery.
我是如何认识你母亲的，这是一个未解之谜。
Let it never be solved, please, please.
让它永远无法解决，拜托，拜托。
It's so insane how Barney just like will be like, okay, let's get out of here.
巴尼会说，好吧，我们离开这里，这太疯狂了。
He'll sneak out, leave this woman and leave this form note, which it's a funny tag.
他会偷偷溜出去，离开这个女人，并留下这张表格，这是一个有趣的标签。
It's a funny tag.
这是一个有趣的标签。
Dear resident.
亲爱的居民。
But he's, yeah, he's really a sociopath in this one.
但他，是的，他确实是一个反社会者。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
We can say that about a lot of us.
我们很多人都可以这么说。
Provided you keep your figure.
只要你保持身材。
Yeah.
是的。
Psychotics.
精神病学。
Psychotic.
精神病。
It is, yeah, it is very casually psychotic, that whole thing.
是的，整件事都是非常随意的精神病。
It's funny.
很有趣。
I often like Barney stuff when you feel like it's full of shit and mostly didn't happen.
我经常喜欢巴尼的东西，当你觉得它充满了狗屎并且大多数都没有发生时。
And this one is like, now this happened.
这就像，现在这件事发生了。
He did this.
他做到了。
He really did this one and that's always a little tricky to think about too long.
他确实做到了这一点，但考虑太久总是有点棘手。
Yeah, he works better as an unreliable narrator.
是的，他作为一个不可靠的叙述者表现得更好。
I think so.
我想是的。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, I think he's more funny and more charming when it's like, I'm not sure that happened the way you said it happened.
就像，我认为他更有趣，更迷人，当我不确定事情是否按照你所说的方式发生时。
And there's something about making it more explicit.
还有一些事情可以让它变得更加明确。
That's a little bit more like, ew, you know, like, this is a person with feelings.
这有点像，呃，你知道，就像，这是一个有感情的人。
You don't want to think about it too long.
你不想考虑太久。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, the good news is down the line, not too far from now, we started deepening it.
好消息即将到来，距离现在不远，我们开始深化它。
and humanizing Barney.
以及人性化的巴尼。
And season one, we of course saw some of his moons, but in episodes like this, he's just a sociopath.
在第一季中，我们当然看到了他的一些月亮，但在这样的剧集中，他只是一个反社会者。
There's no two, there's no, there's no defending it.
没有两个，没有，没有人可以捍卫它。
He's a scorpion, he's a scorpion.
他是蝎子，他是蝎子。
Alec, what do you got for us?
亚历克，你给我们带来了什么？
I had many things.
我有很多东西。
One thing I do want to mention also just, we start on Feel the Dreams.
我确实想提一件事，我们从感受梦想开始。
We can do the Feel the Dreams podcast, but yes, every year on the anniversary of my father's death, which is coming up in 10 days, we would, I would watch Feel the Dreams.
我们可以做“感受梦想”播客，但是，是的，每年在我父亲去世的周年纪念日，也就是十天后，我们都会，我会看“感受梦想”。
And then after the first 20 years, I stopped, but every now and then, we bring it back.
在最初的 20 年之后，我停了下来，但时不时地，我们又把它带回来。
We can do this one forever.
我们可以永远做这件事。
It's just, it's a, I mean, it is the ultimate father-son movie.
这只是，我的意思是，这是一部终极父子电影。
I love that that was your guys movie.
我喜欢那是你们的电影。
I love that you, yeah, keep it alive.
我爱你，是的，保持活力。
That's a tradition.
这是一个传统。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, that's amazing.
就像，这太棒了。
That's a work of art.
那是一件艺术品。
All right, well, I have a message, just a simple message from Chris's song who you can tell us who that is and then I'll read you the very short message.
好吧，我有一条消息，只是克里斯歌曲中的一条简单消息，你可以告诉我们那是谁，然后我会给你读这条非常短的消息。
Great.
伟大的。
Chris was the second second, right?
克里斯是第二个，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, yeah, this is a him-me-em-er.
是的，我的意思是，是的，这是一个他我的游戏。
This is a him-me-em staffer of long-time, wonderful dude.
这是一个他我的工作人员，是一个长期的、出色的家伙。
Like day one to first day to last day, I think.
我想就像第一天到第一天到最后一天一样。
Or maybe he came, oh boy, was he fully door to door?
或者也许他来了，天哪，他是挨家挨户来的吗？
He was there for a huge amount of it.
他在那里承担了巨大的责任。
Chris, we suck, that we're forgetting exactly the most of it anyway.
克里斯，我们很糟糕，无论如何我们都忘记了大部分内容。
Well, I will say that the, so there's the director, the first assistant director, second assistant director, And then the second second, which is, I don't know why they don't call it the third, but it's the second second.
嗯，我会说，所以有导演，第一助理导演，第二助理导演，然后是第二第二，也就是说，我不知道为什么他们不叫它第三，但它是第二第二。
And the second second, their big job is directing the extras, the background actors.
第二秒，他们的主要工作是指导群众演员、背景演员。
So Chris actually, some of those, if you're on enough sets, some of the ways that people talk to the background actors can be incredibly disrespectful and rude.
所以克里斯实际上，如果你在足够多的场景中，人们与背景演员交谈的某些方式可能会非常不尊重和粗鲁。
And Chris was a master at it.
克里斯是这方面的大师。
He was so good at, you know, everyone's while Mike Shea would jump in with a global note, like sexier, really sexy time.
他非常擅长，你知道，每个人的，而迈克·谢伊（Mike Shea）会用全球性的音符跳出来，比如更性感、真正性感的时间。
We're gonna have a sexy, sexy time at the dance.
我们将在舞会上度过一段非常性感的时光。
Look at a dance club.
看看舞蹈俱乐部。
And we had to dance silently.
我们必须默默地跳舞。
It was an order.
这是一个命令。
Yeah, which is the least sexy thing of all time.
是的，这是有史以来最不性感的事情。
But Chris was awesome.
但克里斯很棒。
Chris was on for years and years and years.
克里斯已经上场很多年了。
Great dude.
很棒的家伙。
Yeah, and a big, and wrangling all of that.
是的，还有一大堆争论。
There's a lot, like in a big bar scene, the crossing, the blocking that, what the extras are doing on New York Street, how it all, how it all, the whole puzzle comes together.
有很多，就像在一个大酒吧场景中，交叉路口，阻塞，临时演员在纽约街上做什么，这一切，这一切，整个谜题如何组合在一起。
It's actually a lot.
实际上很多。
Yeah.
是的。
And the rest is typically just as I've been loving and hearing and seeing you guys talk about the old days, great job with William, congratulations.
其余的就像我一直喜欢、听到和看到你们谈论过去的日子一样，威廉干得很好，恭喜。
Oh, thanks Chris.
哦，谢谢克里斯。
Thank you, Chris.
谢谢你，克里斯。
We miss you, buddy.
我们想念你，伙计。
All right, so we have some general questions.
好的，我们有一些一般性问题。
General questions.
一般问题。
Oh, wow, that was finally not me.
哇哦，终于不是我了。
That was me.
那是我。
I'm the internet.
我是互联网。
Okay, Chezan, under school, Faya, under school four, seven, four, F, says, how did Spokane get chosen for the skyscraper site?
好的，Chezan，在学校下，Faya，在学校四、七、四、F 下，说，斯波坎是如何被选为摩天大楼选址的？
It's so far away from New York City and randomly has a vertical building clause that doesn't allow buildings to be taller than a certain height.
它距离纽约市那么远，并且随机有一个垂直建筑条款，不允许建筑物高于一定高度。
I've lived there for several years and always wondered why they didn't have tall buildings like G&B promised.
我在那里住了好几年了，一直想知道为什么他们没有像 G&B 承诺的那样建起高楼。
It is a really huge building in a really small town in retrospect, but the fact that we've in fact checked and debunked, we have absolutely violated the city code or something of Spokane to watch.
回想起来，这是一座位于小镇上的巨大建筑，但事实是我们已经检查并揭穿了这一事实，我们绝对违反了斯波坎的城市法规或其他值得关注的规定。
Okay.
好的。
You got us.
你得到了我们。
What can you do but take the hidden scenario like this?
除了这样的隐藏场景你还能做什么呢？
You got us.
你得到了我们。
Isn't it funny though that the things that people get hooked on, like I'm sure if you're from Spokane, you're like, okay, that's of interest to me.
有趣的是，人们迷上的东西，就像我确信如果你来自斯波坎，你会说，好吧，这对我很感兴趣。
But like out of 208 episodes, all the proper nouns dropped, someone's like, I gotta know.
但就像 208 集一样，所有专有名词都被删除了，有人说，我必须知道。
Why did you violate Spokane's building code?
您为什么违反斯波坎的建筑规范？
Like you can't look.
就像你看不见一样。
This is the Spokane we want to exist.
这就是我们想要存在的斯波坎。
We think there's a lot of promise to build vertically in Spokane.
我们认为斯波坎的垂直建设前景广阔。
We're trying to suddenly put that out there.
我们正试图突然把它放在那里。
It hasn't happened in 20 years.
20年来没有发生过这样的事。
It was basically our only goal with the show was to change the building codes in Spokane, Washington.
基本上，我们演出的唯一目标是改变华盛顿州斯波坎的建筑规范。
This was our main cause of the show.
这是我们举办这个节目的主要原因。
If you're listening, Spokane, it's not too late.
斯波坎，如果你在听的话，现在还不算太晚。
Maybe it was like a mid-size American city that you were just putting your money on.
也许它就像一个美国中型城市，你只是把钱投入其中。
You're like, Spokane is on the up and up by 2035.
你会想，到 2035 年，斯波坎将会变得越来越好。
Spokane is gonna be the spot.
斯波坎就是那个地方。
I cannot for the life of me tell you why we chose Spokane, Washington.
我无法告诉你为什么我们选择华盛顿州斯波坎。
There's no good story here.
这里没有什么好故事。
Did we throw a dart at a map?
我们向地图扔了飞镖吗？
And I don't know what the fuck, but I guess it wasn't that we wanted Ted's first building to be like, it's right next to the Empire State Building.
我不知道他妈的是什么，但我想这并不是我们想要特德的第一座建筑，它就在帝国大厦旁边。
You know what, it should be like, it's somewhere random.
你知道吗，它应该是这样的，它在某个随机的地方。
Right, right.
对，对。
He needed to start in smaller markets.
他需要从较小的市场开始。
Yeah, smaller markets, yeah.
是的，较小的市场，是的。
You talked about this a little bit at the beginning.
您一开始就谈到了这一点。
We'll see if there's anything else to mine from it.
我们会看看是否还能从中挖掘出其他东西。
And just to note that others did note this, some dot artist dot out dot there says, as many other hymium episodes this one introduced me to one of my favorite songs and bands of all time.
只是要注意其他人确实注意到了这一点，一些点艺术家点了点那里说的，正如许多其他 hymium 剧集一样，这一集向我介绍了我一直以来最喜欢的歌曲和乐队之一。
With here I jumped I was an architect by the Decemberists.
在这里我跳了起来，我是十二月党的建筑师。
Hemium always had some exquisite indie music that I end up loving dearly.
Hemium 总是有一些精致的独立音乐，我最终非常喜欢它们。
I wanted to ask if you realized at the time that the song's lyrics have some romantic themes that line up very nicely with Robin and Ted's relationship, or was it just chosen because it had the word architect in the title?
我想问你当时是否意识到这首歌的歌词有一些浪漫的主题，与罗宾和泰德的关系非常吻合，或者只是因为标题中有“建筑师”一词而选择它？
Definitely the latter at first.
首先肯定是后者。
I mean, it was definitely like, like I said, one of our writers, Gloria, put it on the mix because it's an architect, I think.
我的意思是，就像我说的，我们的一位作家格洛丽亚将其加入其中，因为我认为它是一位建筑师。
But the tone and the feeling and the vibe of it, it's very Ted.
但它的语气、感觉和氛围，非常特德。
I like what Cam's at the beginning of this whole episode.
我喜欢卡姆在整集开头的内容。
It's Ted.
这是特德。
There's Ted's soul is rhyming and echoing with these songs in some way, and that one definitely hasn't.
泰德的灵魂以某种方式与这些歌曲押韵和呼应，而那首歌绝对没有。
You're right.
你说得对。
When you listen to the lyrics, it's very smart, it's very heartfelt, and there's a little bit of sweetness in there.
听歌词的话，很灵动，很用心，还有一点点甜蜜在里面。
It's a very hymnmium song.
这是一首非常赞美诗。
So yeah, I think it starts a lot.
是的，我认为这有很多开始。
I don't know if you have this, Craig, but a lot of times with music, I'll get hooked by the melody or even the title.
我不知道你是否有这个，克雷格，但很多时候在音乐方面，我会被旋律甚至标题迷住。
And that's what will take me into the song.
这就是将我带入这首歌的原因。
And then I spend a little more time with song and I realize, oh no, the lyrics are actually where the heart of it lies and what I was almost being invited towards.
然后我花了更多的时间在歌曲上，我意识到，哦不，歌词实际上是它的核心所在，也是我几乎被邀请去做的。
There's a lot of ways to go into a song.
进入歌曲的方式有很多种。
Even like your song that is the theme song of this podcast, I was listening to it today and it really jumped out of me telling you everything in New York City.
就像这个播客的主题曲一样，我今天听它时，我真的跳出来告诉你纽约市的一切。
It allowed me to tell you everything.
它让我可以告诉你一切。
That sentiment of I want to tell you a story, like, somehow today, more than ever, we're like 50 episodes into this thing, whatever we are.
我想告诉你一个故事，就像，不知何故，今天，比以往任何时候都更多，我们就像这件事的 50 集，无论我们是什么。
I was like, oh, that really works for how I'm going to tell you everything.
我当时想，哦，这真的很适合我告诉你一切。
And this old man must admit he fell in love with you in New York City.
这位老人必须承认他在纽约爱上了你。
You didn't write it to be the theme song of this podcast, for example.
例如，您没有将其写为该播客的主题曲。
But sometimes these things, like there's some weird mystical thing that just rhymes together, things go together, lyrics and melodies that the song, the December song somehow rhymes with Ted.
但有时这些事情，比如有一些奇怪的神秘的东西，只是押韵在一起，事情在一起，歌词和旋律，这首歌，十二月的歌曲不知何故与泰德押韵。
I think we only put it on there at first because it would set architect and this was Ted Mosby architect.
我想我们一开始只是把它放在那里，因为它会设置建筑师，这是特德·莫斯比建筑师。
And then you're like, oh, this absolutely works.
然后你会想，哦，这绝对有效。
That's the magic, right?
这就是魔法，对吧？
That's the magic of just fitting it all together, the puzzle coming together.
这就是将所有东西组合在一起、将拼图拼凑在一起的魔力。
And even the choice to make him an architect, it's kind of, you know, it's kind of like a dart board of romantic comedy professions, right?
甚至选择让他成为一名建筑师，这有点像浪漫喜剧职业的飞镖盘，对吧？
But there's something in this particular show where it's a guy constructing or reconstructing rather his story but he in the present is really building brick by brick his life you know becomes like a much bigger metaphor yeah it's not going to be that building until many many years from now and we don't know what's gonna look like right yeah and that was definitely part of why we made that in architecture because we we thought it was meta for the whole endeavor by the way speaking of me speaking of music just a plug for an interview I as recline interviewed Brian Eno.
但在这个特定的节目中，有一些东西是一个人在构建或重建他的故事，但他现在确实是一砖一瓦地建造，他的生活变得像一个更大的隐喻，是的，直到许多年以后，它才会成为那个建筑，我们不知道会是什么样子，是的，这绝对是我们在建筑中这样做的部分原因，因为我们认为这是整个努力的元，说到我谈到音乐，只是一个采访的插件，我作为倾斜采访了布莱恩·伊诺。
Oh cool.
哦，酷。
And it's fantastic.
这太棒了。
But he talks about as an artist, he he makes a distinction between being an architect and a gardener or a farmer.
但他谈到作为一名艺术家时，他区分了建筑师和园丁或农民。
And he says he always wants to be a gardener or a farmer and not an architect because the architect has plans, they know where they're headed and then someone executes those plans and it's kind of fixed where you're going.
他说他一直想成为一名园丁或农民，而不是一名建筑师，因为建筑师有计划，他们知道自己要去哪里，然后有人执行这些计划，而你要去的地方是固定的。
He said a gardener is like you plant the seeds and you tend to it and it kind of Nature takes over at some point and you're watering it, you're tending to it, you're seeing your marsh, you know, you're putting some guardrails around it.
他说，园丁就像你种下种子，你照料它，在某个时候，大自然会接管它，你给它浇水，你照料它，你看到你的沼泽，你知道，你在它周围设置一些护栏。
But I just, I thought that distinction was really cool.
但我只是觉得这种区别真的很酷。
And I can't recommend that highly enough, that interview was really, I found it very moving.
我怎么推荐都不为过，那次采访真的非常令人感动。
Derek Wareman asks, since we know this was beginning based off Carter and Craig and their lives in relationships, where do they end in the characters begin?
德里克·韦尔曼问道，既然我们知道这是基于卡特和克雷格以及他们的人际关系生活开始的，那么他们在角色中的结局是从哪里开始的？
Like, where was the point in in these storylines that are not something they went through and not true at all to who they were as people?
比如，这些故事情节的重点在哪里，这些故事情节不是他们经历过的事情，也根本不符合他们作为人的真实身份？
Immediately it begins, it begins in the pilot.
它立即开始，从飞行员开始。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
It really is, it's just a tone, it's a weigh-in.
确实如此，这只是一种语气，这是一种权衡。
It's our connection to these characters was a weigh-in and then you get these wonderful actors who teach you all these things about these characters and on all these things about what they, the actors, are good at and can surprise you with.
我们与这些角色的联系是一种权衡，然后你会得到这些出色的演员，他们会教你所有关于这些角色的事情，以及他们作为演员所擅长的事情，并且可以给你带来惊喜。
And you chase that as much as you keep alive connection to the characters as a show runner or show creator, but you have to let it grow into other things.
作为节目主持人或节目创作者，你会尽可能地追求与角色之间的联系，但你必须让它发展成其他东西。
And it starts immediately, I think, right?
我想它会立即开始，对吗？
Episode two.
第二集。
After Craig proposed to Rebecca and popped a champagne cork into her eye and she had to go to the hospital.
克雷格向丽贝卡求婚，并将香槟瓶塞塞进她的眼睛后，丽贝卡不得不去医院。
That's the thing.
就是这样。
You're just looking for the emotional way into these characters.
你只是在寻找这些角色的情感方式。
And then we never knew we're going to do 208 episodes.
然后我们从来不知道我们会拍 208 集。
But if you remained like too slavish to like, this has to be literally our lives or it doesn't feel true or we can't write it.
但如果你仍然太奴性而无法喜欢，那么这必须是我们的生活，否则感觉不真实，或者我们无法写它。
No, you want to go find shit out.
不，你想出去看看。
Like even in this episode, like it was fun for Josh to play this break, like he said, like it was funny.
就像在这一集中，乔希玩这个休息很有趣，就像他说的，就像这很有趣。
This was a different speed for Josh to do for Ted to see Ted do.
对于乔希来说，这是一个不同的速度，而泰德则看到了泰德所做的事情。
You want to find those things.
你想要找到那些东西。
You got to keep it interesting.
你必须让它保持有趣。
And yeah, certainly this story never happened in this episode.
是的，当然这个故事在这一集中从未发生过。
Well, it's also cool.
嗯，这也很酷。
The more we talk, Craig, the more you realize, I mean, I'm re-realizing it, but also the listener, that this show, it's a hive mind, the writer's room is a hive mind.
克雷格，我们说得越多，你就越意识到，我的意思是，我正在重新意识到这一点，但听众也意识到，这个节目，它是一个蜂巢思维，作家的房间是一个蜂巢思维。
So like, Courtney Kang steals little things to write the karma in the world, you know, that finds its way in.
就像，考特尼·康（Courtney Kang）偷了一些小东西来写下世界上的业力，你知道，这会找到它的方式。
That did not come from you in Carter, right?
卡特那话不是你说的，对吧？
What would Courtney arrested retroactively for having talked about this as much?
考特尼会因为谈论了这么多而追溯性地逮捕什么？
She's a vigilante.
她是一名义务警员。
Courtney Kang, she's out there.
考特尼·康，她就在那里。
But only for good.
但只是为了好的。
Courtney, you're doing it for good.
考特尼，你这样做是为了做好事。
Yeah.
是的。
To teach a lesson.
来教训一下。
But no, it's cool.
但不，这很酷。
It's cool to know where these different things came from and also when you don't remember which is more the case.
知道这些不同的东西从哪里来，以及当你不记得哪个更重要时，这很酷。
Much more the case.
情况更是如此。
You don't remember.
你不记得了。
It's just like, it just came out of the room, you know?
就像它刚刚从房间里出来一样，你知道吗？
It's just the magic.
这只是魔法。
It's the magic of the thing.
这就是事情的魔力。
It's why do those lyrics fit with this thing?
这就是为什么那些歌词适合这个东西？
I had what came first, the melody of the lyrics, does the melody of the same meaning as lyrics.
我先有了歌词的旋律，旋律和歌词的意思是一样的吗？
It's all, it has so many moving parts.
就是这样，它有很多活动部件。
really does feel like the magic and the mystery to be very cheesy of what it is to be creative, right?
创意真的很俗气，感觉很神奇和神秘，对吧？
Ideally, you can't even reconstruct how you got to a thing, because it's too very, too many things went into it.
理想情况下，你甚至无法重建你是如何得到一件事的，因为它包含了太多太多的东西。
I forget what is a line I wrote, or what is a line Carter wrote, or what did this come from someone else's lights?
我忘记了我写的哪一行，或者卡特写的哪一行，或者这来自别人的灯光？
This is kind of like my lip.
这有点像我的嘴唇。
I can't remember, and it is.
我不记得了，但确实如此。
It's a hive mind.
这是一个蜂巢思维。
Something happens in a good writer's room, where it just becomes like one big brain thinking.
在一位优秀作家的房间里会发生一些事情，就像一个大大脑在思考一样。
Yeah, and then you leap off the other person's idea, like three average jokes lead to the one, you know?
是的，然后你就跳出了对方的想法，就像三个普通的笑话引出了一个，你知道吗？
But those average jokes are like vital.
但那些普通的笑话却至关重要。
Yeah, you have to start somewhere.
是的，你必须从某个地方开始。
You don't find the twist unless you start with the thing and then you find the twist on the twist on the twist and that's what's beautiful.
除非你从事情开始，然后你在扭曲上发现扭曲，这就是美丽的东西，否则你找不到扭曲。
Brian, you know, does a beautiful deep dive into what troubles him from a creative standpoint about AI and large language models.
你知道，布莱恩从人工智能和大型语言模型的创造性角度深入探讨了困扰他的问题。
And one of the things he said, he was a watercolor painter when he was younger.
他说，他年轻时是一名水彩画家。
And he said, at the end of the day, no matter what he was painting, no matter what the color palette was, the water at the end was always the same bland brownish gray color, no matter what.
他说，在一天结束时，无论他画什么，无论调色板是什么，最后的水总是相同的温和的棕灰色，无论如何。
And he gave a name for the color.
他还给这种颜色起了一个名字。
He called it Munch, which is a great name.
他称其为蒙克，这是一个伟大的名字。
He said, the color is Munch.
他说，颜色是蒙克。
Munch, what a good word.
蒙克，多好的词啊。
And it was just this undistinguished kind of bland blah of a color.
这只是一种平淡无奇的颜色。
And he said, his experience is when you start working creatively with AI, it feels vibrant and alive.
他说，他的经验是，当你开始使用人工智能进行创造性工作时，会感觉充满活力和活力。
And he said, an hour in, it's munch.
他说，一个小时后，就可以了。
Like it's like, it's just, it just becomes munch.
就像它一样，它只是，它只是变得咀嚼。
It just becomes this kind of, and I think there's something about, when you get, you know, I feel strongly like defensive of human beings in creative, in the creative act, as AI comes more and more knocking.
它就变成了这样，我认为，当你知道，当人工智能越来越多地敲门时，我强烈地感觉到在创造性、创造性行为中对人类进行防御。
And there's something about this show.
这个节目有一些东西。
I mean, how many mothers say what you want about it, it's not munch.
我的意思是，有多少妈妈说你想要什么，这不是咀嚼。
It has its own vibrant talent.
它有自己充满活力的才华。
It's very specific.
这是非常具体的。
And to me, it's kind of like an artifact of like, it's handmade, it's hand-woven, it's artisanal.
对我来说，它有点像一件工艺品，它是手工制作的，它是手工编织的，它是手工的。
This was made by humans, you know, for a multi-cat national corporation.
你知道，这是人类为一家多猫国家公司制造的。
But it was made by humans.
但它是人类制造的。
It was made by humans.
它是由人类制造的。
We have to say that.
我们必须这么说。
They make us say that.
他们让我们这么说。
Our overlords are corporations, we say that.
我们这么说，我们的霸主是公司。
We got a letter, and I'm gonna read it right now.
我们收到一封信，我现在就读。
Hi guys, my name is Sebastian, and I am from Mexico City.
大家好，我叫塞巴斯蒂安，来自墨西哥城。
I think I pronounced it correctly.
我想我发音正确。
I discovered him because my sister started watching when I was 11, 11's like to cut off, I think.
我发现他是因为我姐姐在我 11 岁的时候就开始看他了，我想 11 岁的时候就喜欢停播了。
I remember being at a Father's Day party with my whole family feeling extremely isolated and alone.
我记得有一次父亲节聚会，全家人都感到非常孤立和孤独。
I slipped away to my father's studio, looked for him on a not so legal website.
我溜到父亲的工作室，在一个不那么合法的网站上寻找他。
And in that moment, I found a safe place, somewhere I didn't have to worry about how I felt for a while and where I could lose myself in an interesting story.
在那一刻，我找到了一个安全的地方，在那里我暂时不必担心自己的感受，也可以在一个有趣的故事中迷失自己。
The show helped me get through high school it became one of the things I shared with my very first love.
这个节目帮助我度过了高中，它成为我与我的初恋分享的事情之一。
Since then, Hemium has always been with me.
从那时起，Hemium 就一直伴随着我。
It has helped me through breakups, fights, loss, loneliness, and even depression, which has been a struggle for me since I was young.
它帮助我度过了分手、争吵、失落、孤独，甚至抑郁，这些从我年轻的时候起就一直困扰着我。
When I was 18 at my graduation, my sister gave me the complete box set of the series.
当我 18 岁毕业时，我姐姐给了我该系列的完整套装。
She told me, since you are starting college, life is going to get harder.
她告诉我，自从你开始上大学，生活就会变得更加艰难。
You will feel confused, alone, and everything will change.
你会感到困惑、孤独，一切都会改变。
I know how life can feel at this time, so I want you to have this to remind you that your life is just beginning.
我知道此时生活的感受，所以我希望你能以此来提醒你，你的生活才刚刚开始。
No matter what happens, you can always come back to where you feel at home.
无论发生什么，您总可以回到家的感觉。
You might need it sometime.
有时你可能需要它。
Because of that, Himyim not only helped me build a stronger relationship with her, but it also became a tradition for me.
正因为如此，Himyim 不仅帮助我与她建立了更牢固的关系，而且这也成为了我的传统。
I've watched the show at least twice a year ever since, and it will always be a part of me.
从那以后我每年至少看两次这个节目，它将永远成为我的一部分。
Now at 25, I know the show by heart, and I cannot stress enough how relevant it has been in my life, always reminding me of the things i needed to hear at just the right time i was hesitant to write this but listen to the podcast almost brought me to tears hearing how other people feel the same way about the show i am truly glad i found it can you miss out me believe that everything that has happened in my life had a reason because one day i will be able to tell my story to thank you wholeheartedly for this for the love you poured into the show and for the decision to revisit it now Yeah, I'm I'm stuck on the illegally downloading So not cool did it did it come with a check Alec like back a I didn't see one I looked I looked I That was amazing.
现在我已经25岁了，我对这个节目了如指掌，我无法充分强调它与我的生活有多么相关，总是提醒我需要在正确的时间听到的事情，我在犹豫要不要写这篇文章，但听播客几乎让我流泪，听到其他人对这个节目的感受我真的很高兴我发现你能错过我相信我生命中发生的一切都有一个原因，因为有一天我将能够讲述我的故事来全心全意地感谢你这是为了你对这部剧的热爱，也是为了现在重温它的决定，是的，我被非法下载困住了，所以不酷，它有没有像亚历克那样附有一张支票，我没有看到，我看了，我看了，太棒了。
That was an amazing letter.
那是一封令人惊奇的信。
That was beautiful beautiful Beautiful.
那真是美丽美丽美丽。
I imagine it must be I mean there is a sense like when you love something that it's yours Yeah, and there can be a little bit heartbreak when you're like oh no other people feel this way about it Right to but you also can feel like you're a part of a tribe or community.
我想一定是这样，我的意思是，当你喜欢某样东西时，就会有一种感觉，它是你的，是的，当你想，哦，没有其他人有这样的感觉，没错，但你也会觉得自己是部落或社区的一部分，这可能会有点心碎。
Yeah that you share something with I also think it's very interesting I was I was I went to a memorial for a playwright that I worked with a few times who was just a genius named Richard Greenberg and he wrote so many brilliant plays.
是的，你和我分享了一些东西，我也觉得这很有趣，我去了一位剧作家的纪念馆，我曾与他合作过几次，他是一位天才，名叫理查德·格林伯格，他写了很多精彩的戏剧。
And I was talking with some people afterwards and I was talking with this actress and we were talking about how the phenomenon that everyone feels old all the time.
后来我和一些人聊天，我和这位女演员聊天，我们谈论每个人都感觉自己老了的现象。
Like no matter how old you are.
就像无论你多大年纪一样。
Like I hear from people in their 20s who were like, my life is over, I don't know where I'm going.
就像我听到 20 多岁的人说，我的生命结束了，我不知道我要去哪里。
Like it's too late for me.
好像对我来说已经太晚了。
And it's like, you're 22 years old.
就像，你已经22岁了。
I remember feeling that way at 19.
我记得19岁时就有这种感觉。
Oh yeah, well also the beginning of how I met your mother is, I'm 27, life is passing me by.
哦，是的，我认识你妈妈的开始也是，我27岁了，生活正在流逝。
I have to get my life started, you know?
我必须开始我的生活，你知道吗？
It's so funny to rewatch that.
重看一遍真是太有趣了。
We probably really meant it at the time.
我们当时可能真的是这么想的。
Like I remember being in my 20s and 30s and feeling kind of old.
就像我记得我20多岁和30多岁的时候，感觉有点老了。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
And now I look back and I'm like buddy.
现在我回想起来，我就像朋友一样。
We're way fucking older now.
我们现在已经老了很多了。
We're way older now.
现在我们已经老了很多了。
Do you know what that letter reminded me of?
你知道那封信让我想起了什么吗？
First of all, I wanna say that letter was absolutely beautiful.
首先，我想说那封信非常漂亮。
Thank you for sharing that.
感谢您分享这一点。
I'm so glad the show found you in the way that it did.
我很高兴这部剧以这样的方式找到了你。
Sebastian, I'm hoping, and now I'm not saying his name correctly, but you know what it made me think of and that I love is the older sister, like, bestowing, like, gifting this thing to the, almost famous, you and Josh, we still have the magic, that's exactly where I was going with that.
塞巴斯蒂安，我希望，现在我没有正确地说出他的名字，但你知道它让我想到了什么，我爱的是姐姐，就像，赠予，就像，把这个东西送给几乎出名的你和乔什，我们仍然有魔力，这正是我想要的。
Almost famous, here's this mysterious box.
几乎出名了，这就是这个神秘的盒子。
Like, did she even, he even said the box that is, she gave me the box that?
就像，她甚至，他甚至说过那个盒子，也就是说，她给了我那个盒子吗？
This show will make you cool.
这个节目会让你很酷。
If you listen to this with a candlelet, you'll see your future, like it really had that feeling of that the cool older sister giving the thing to the kid.
如果你拿着蜡烛听这首歌，你会看到你的未来，就像真的有那种酷姐姐把东西送给孩子的感觉。
The fact that in this case, I mean, almost famous, it's all the greatest records of all time.
事实上，在这种情况下，我的意思是，几乎是出名的，它都是有史以来最伟大的唱片。
The fact that she did this with how I met your mother just means the world and I'm so glad it found you and met you where you were and needed it.
事实上，她在我遇见你母亲的过程中做到了这一点，这一事实意味着整个世界，我很高兴它找到了你，并在你所在的地方遇见了你，并在你需要的地方遇见了你。
And I'm glad it strengthened your relationship with your sister too, which is a really moving part of the- That's like my favorite part of almost famous is the older sister that gives a goose.
我很高兴它也加强了你和你姐姐的关系，这是一个非常感人的部分——就像我最喜欢的部分几乎出名的是姐姐给鹅一样。
I'm an only child and I think like, I wish I had a cool older sibling like, here's all the records you need to have heard.
我是独生子，我想，我希望我有一个很酷的哥哥姐姐，这是你需要听的所有唱片。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I didn't have that and I just love that aspect of that letter.
我没有，但我只是喜欢那封信的这一方面。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
If you want to send us a voice note or send us a written letter, please go to how we made your mother.com.
如果您想向我们发送语音留言或向我们发送书面信件，请访问我们如何创建您的 mother.com。
William.com will also work.
William.com 也可以使用。
Go to contact, follow the directions, the prompts, it'll be pretty easy from there, but we'd love to either read your letter on the air or play your voice note on the air.
转到联系方式，按照说明和提示进行操作，从那里开始一切都会非常简单，但我们很乐意在广播中阅读您的信件或在广播中播放您的语音留​​言。
It's truly been one of our favorite parts of this adventure we've been on, this revisiting of the show, is hearing from people who've been watching it and why they love it, and why they continue to love it.
这确实是我们在这次冒险中最喜欢的部分之一，这次重温这部剧，是听到看过它的人的来信，以及他们为什么喜欢它，以及为什么他们继续喜欢它。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购 Craig Thomas 的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》、Wherever Books Are Sold，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。